hey friends welcome back to deep dive
this episode is a conversation with
julian hearn the founder of huel hill is
the multi-million dollar powdered food
replacement company that i've actually
been using since 2017. and julian's
story is particularly interesting
because he started this company at the
age of 37 and started off his career
digging holes in a road and working
night shifts at a petrol station these
days we hear a lot of stories about
entrepreneurship and founders who
started companies and started doing cool
things at the age of like 17 or 18 or
19. and if you're older than that it can
be easy to think that you're too late to
get started if you want to do it
yourself hopefully this interview will
show you that that's not the case and
that you can just kind of do this kind
of stuff basically whenever you want and
it can be successful if you apply it
kind of the right way and you enjoy
yourself along the way which is what
we're all about here but yeah i hope you
enjoyed this conversation between me and
julian hearn so i've been evangelizing
fuel since about like 2017 when i first
discovered it um and
i was using it a lot when i was in med
school going from placement here and
there because i'd skip meals and skip
breakfast but just having the powder at
the time and now the pre-made stuff is
absolutely sick
but i still get weird looks when people
are like heel like why'd you do that
like doesn't it take the joy out of life
to do and i'm like oh
no it doesn't it's like just like a meal
replacement for like if if i if i it's
better than a sugary like breakfast
cereal yeah how how do you guys think
about the whole
it it it feels unpalatable to be
drinking your meals okay vibe
well we have we have products you don't
have to drink if that's not what we want
to do but in terms of this um this joy
element it's quite interesting i used to
debate quite a lot on uh facebook with
people who's answering this and i was
explaining to people you've got to
separate happiness from pleasure so
really when people are talking about joy
they're really talking about pleasure
yeah so you know when you sort of eat a
sugary thing it will stimulate your
pleasure senses it's not making you
happier so you know happiness is much
harder to achieve much more long-term
much more fundamental but it's pleasure
but really you know drugs give you
pleasure alcohol gives you pleasure so
actually pleasure is typically not a bad
thing it usually leads to bad habits so
going back to food lots of people get
pleasure from food
but that pleasure is actually going to
end up with them possibly over indulging
eating way too much no cake might give
you pleasure it's probably not a very
good food for you he wouldn't have that
for breakfast lunch and dinner so i
think you have to be very careful and
separate and happiness and i think joy
is a word that probably sits somewhere
in between but really it's on the it's
on the side really of the pleasure but
just think if you have too much pleasure
from food you're probably gonna have
health problems
probably weight problems probably going
to be inefficient so we try to separate
that out so we say that shield is he's
never going to replace a um
your sunday dinner he's never going to
place your saturday night takeaway he's
never going to place your your um
a restaurant meal but what it is really
good at doing is giving you functional
food which gives you the nutrition which
your body needs in the most convenient
format and ensures you get all of the
nutrition and
i use it for breakfast and lunch during
the working week which are my most
inconvenient meals and not social media
typically you're on a rush
so i have it for roughly 10 meals a week
which is basically nearly half my meal
so instantly i get high quality
nutrition
uh very conveniently
and they're plant-based so i'm sort of
50 vegan without even trying
and so i think overall it gives me what
i need and then i can i can have a
traditional family meal in the evenings
without any sort of compromise in my
there's no problem at all there's a
balance between the two if you know if
people said you know if you had a sunday
dinner every day for every meal it's
gonna be super inconvenient super
expensive super time consuming and not
necessarily nutrition complete so i
think people forget we sort of we've
been trained that food is
an art form something you indulge in
something you spend a lot of time on but
really your food is nutrition there's a
very specific list pretty much identical
across the whole world from all the
doctors and scientists they pretty much
agree it's pretty much identical what
you actually do need to eat in terms of
the specific
macro micronutrients
and
we provide that but you try and do that
from natural food sources super hard to
do unless you've got a spreadsheet so
you're sort of guessing most of the time
in terms of even calories let alone the
26 bits that you actually need so we do
that for you you don't have to worry at
all so you can relax the rest of time
and eat what you want the rest of the
time i was uh i was thinking in the
shower this morning um because
whenever we're we're here in studio
which is most days each week um we just
order from some random takeaway from
deliveroo and i was thinking our default
at the moment is like chipotle chicken
salad but today i was like oh you know
we've been having chipotle chicken salad
for the last couple you know what let's
get an unhealthy chinese takeaway type
thing and i was thinking you know it
would be cool if we had like a fridge
that just had the pre-made heels just
stocked like i do um because in in in my
flattened king's cross we have a wine
fridge which has been replaced with the
heel fridge so it's got the banana one
is my favorite um and uh the salted
caramel i think was good i've been
having recently um
so i've been thinking of like
incorporating that into the team and i
was just thinking huh i wonder how
people would feel about that i'm sure we
could bring a fridge along i think we
sorted somebody else with a shield
fridge a few places oh have you guys got
branded fridges we've got some bread and
fridges
yeah that'd be glorious we have a brand
new fridge have you tried the hot and
savory one as well so we was talking
about drinking your food i used to have
those a lot in during during lockdown
one yeah um that was quite nice the
tomato uh
one herb tomato and herb one yeah we've
got some new ones now we've got a couple
of pasta ones which have gone extremely
well yeah so we've got chicken and
mushroom we've got cajun pasta we've got
mac and cheese or vegan mac and cheese
um yeah we'll get you some of those we
said earlier i'll give you a big box of
stuff and get some loads of stuff i
wanted to kind of take you back to when
when when all this stuff started because
you're just about to turn 50. is that
right right and you started um i was i
was i was trying to work out what age
you started various companies and it was
like surprisingly later in life than
people would initially think people
think founders like you know 17 to 19
year olds mark zuckerberg the stripe
guys yeah um but you were like 30
something when you started i would have
been 36 37
and um yeah i yeah
most of these sort of podcasts can focus
around the sort of very younger guys
and yeah you think about the zuckerberg
as the world's incredibly young well i
think you've done ben francis recently
incredibly young so i think that it's um
yeah i think it's interesting that most
people probably think when they get 36
day seven they're sort of stuck in what
they're doing yeah they can't retrain
they can't relearn
but yeah i did i just sort of had a had
a need i had a personal reason why i
needed to start working from home
and i had to suss that out and i did a
lot of stuff you sort of do is listen to
a lot of podcasts tons of podcasts read
a lot online and try and work out and
sort of bodge your way through to start
off with so it took me about a year
before i got the confidence to jack my
job in but worked evenings and weekends
yeah it must be 36.37 yeah so when you
so um i i speak to a lot of people in
there like sometimes even late teens but
like early to mid 20s who say oh i don't
know what i want to do i haven't figured
it out it seems like all these other
people are sort of like going ahead of
me yeah um
what was your kind of experiences during
school and sort of like late teens early
20s um and how did how did we go from
that to
and then
starting a business like this so i left
school at 16.
um pretty poor gcses um what did i get
three c's maybe these e's got two e's
for english i do remember that i can't
spell i'm not really gonna read it
either really it's got two years of
english left at 16
worked at a shop for a year then worked
digging holes in the road for two years
as manual labor
um
then i think my girlfriend at time was
about 90 she goes what are you doing are
you digging holes in the road you're too
smart to do that so i wasn't
academically smart but i saw quite smart
at certain stuff
so i went back to college
two years
and i thought i'd come out there and get
a job came out of college with two
i think it was a b tech i had couldn't
get a job off the back of that so i had
nothing else to do really apart from
went to uniform and now i'm committed
i've given up work i might as well keep
going so then i got a placement at
bournemouth university did a degree in
marketing came out of that thought i'd
get a job straight away no problem
didn't i scan work and i remember i
worked night shift in the petrol station
for six months
and um
and then luckily i think it was my
stepmom she worked with somebody whose
husband worked somewhere and luckily i
got a job in marketing finally after all
that so i'd had a degree mark i had a
2-1 but couldn't get a job luckily i got
one
uh i worked in a marketing team
from about i think that must be 1999
something like that worked in marketing
for mostly retailers so that was when
you were like 25 fish yeah yeah maybe a
little bit older 25 26 something like
that and um
and then then i started uh internet sort
of came along yeah so this was still
quite early because i think when i was
at uni i think i was finished union 96
and the internet right really not really
about you know i think i think at
university you could go and use some of
the computers there you could access the
internet but nobody really had a home
computer internet 96
and um
and then when i first got my job i was
just doing normal sort of marketing as a
marketing assistant and then the
internet came along so somebody said can
you have a look at this internet thing
should we have an internet business i
was working for mfi which is a furniture
retailer at the time and i sort of said
to them yeah it looks like you should
um bnq which was a bigger retailer at
the time had a what they called a
brochure where site hadn't you couldn't
buy no e-commerce i said well we could
we could beat them we could overtake
them if you give me some money so i sort
of persuaded the the team or the board
to give us
67 000 pounds and start the first
website
got that built by an agency
got that going and then of course i was
almost a you know within one year i was
almost a gray beard in terms of internet
experience because nobody had it so then
i moved on work for some other retailers
and then fast forward to
um
yeah 2000 and
2008 i think it was
um
i needed to work from home
because of a personal reason
and um
i thought [ __ ] what i'm going to do
because i lived in the house we were out
and saw it out in the countryside i was
working in london and going an hour and
a half each week so it was three hours
of driving a day
so i wanted to work from home no
marketing jobs of any sort of merit in
in aylesbury area so i needed to create
my own business
and uh so i started looking around and
luckily at the time we were using some
affiliates and affiliates are people
basically who sit at home and create
websites
and make money from sitting in their pjs
i suppose at home yeah this is something
i can do maybe these guys i met i met
them i went to an affiliate event and uh
these guys i thought they're making i
knew how much something someone's making
like 10 20 000 pounds a month holy [ __ ]
it's loads of money
and um
and i met them i thought they've got to
be i don't know i'm not saying their
flight is going to be geniuses but when
i met them i thought they're they're
bright but they're not like rocket
scientists i thought if they can do it
why can't i do it so that was basically
me then thought right i'm gonna learn
how to do this by myself by listening to
podcasts
by practicing starting websites learning
learning learning yeah so i used to get
home from work at say six o'clock
on a work day
um
have my
meal
with my my wife at a time
and then go on the computer at seven
o'clock i basically had my computer
there set up in the lounge so i could
sit in the lounge watch tv i had a
little mirror set up i could use to
watch the tv while i was uh working yeah
and work to say 11 o'clock do this at
the weekends as well did that nearly
sort of full time for
a year yeah until i got staged i started
making about a thousand pounds maybe
fifteen hundred two thousand pounds a
month
and started thinking i know how to do
this if i had more time i could double
the amount of work i would double the
amount of money i could earn
and so i remember saying to my wife at
the time said right i'm going to have a
crack at this
i'm going to jack my job in
i'm going to give myself six months if i
can't get the same amount of money i get
my salary within six months i'll go back
and get that job again or get a similar
type of job and i think at that time i
had a good enough experience that i felt
confident i could go back and get a job
so it felt like pretty low risk
and i thought as long as i could earn
the same salary
and i'm working from home it's a win-win
i've got three hours a day i'm not
traveling so that was the goal within
three months i was earning more than my
salary and then he just kept on going
after that lots of us go through life
with a bit of a love-hate relationship
with stem subjects in theory the idea of
learning how the world works in science
and learning how to build websites with
computer science is really awesome but
when you're plotting your way through
formulas in a science class or trying to
understand code it can be a bit dry and
boring the way i like to learn more
about this stuff in a fun and engaging
way is with brilliant with kindly
sponsoring this episode brilliant have a
ton of courses that teach maths science
and computer science with visual
examples and interactive challenges
along the way so that you can learn by
doing one of my favorite courses in
brilliant is actually the computer
science series especially the
introduction to algorithms and the
fundamentals of programming with python
i was actually considering applying for
computer science rather than medicine at
university and i ended up going down the
medicine route which i don't regret but
i never really understood computer
science and although i knew how to code
i didn't really understand the
foundational algorithms and structures
behind the field of computer science so
i really enjoyed checking out
brilliant's courses on that and also
their course on cryptocurrency is
absolutely sick and without that course
i really would not have understood how
bitcoin for example works anyway if you
want to improve your math science and
computer science then head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to sign up via
that link will get 20 off the annual
subscription to brilliant so thank you
very much brilliant for sponsoring this
video yeah i think that's uh when i
think when when when people quit a job
um
i feel like they often have this idea
that you know i'm working a 30k job
therefore quitting the job is a 30k risk
it's actually not because like next week
you could probably get a 28k job if you
really wanted to and so really it's not
a 30k risk it's a 2k risk between the
job that you currently have and the job
that you could pretty easily get if you
need it to and even if you take a little
bit of a pay card maybe you can't get a
35k job immediately but at least a 25
28k job is is very reasonable in that
context um and i don't know anyone who's
kind of done done that and regretted the
decision because you're sort of like
going all in on yourself and giving
yourself that be like yeah i'm
i've i've i've got to make this work and
if i don't then it's not the end it's
not the end of the world i'll just get
another job if you talk about it and
sort of practice at it forever you're
never going to do it so you do have to
make that hard decision to do it yeah
but i would never i never would have
done it before i'd been yet practicing
and learning for a year so evening
weekends was vitally important i think
if you do that and really do it and
start earning money you build confidence
the more you do something the more
confidence you get so i was pretty
confident the end of that year
i said if i double the amount of time i
can work on this or triple amount of
times i probably could have tripled the
amount of time i know i will do this
yeah so i was pretty confident but yeah
i'd put enough money to one side to pay
the mortgage pay all the bills for six
months which is not a lot if you just
strip everything out your life apart
from the mortgage and the food bills you
don't need that much so it wasn't a ton
of cash but i put enough money in the
bank that had that saved that up over
that previous year for the money i had
to earn from it put that to one side
that was enough
um but yeah it was three months and i
was earning more yeah so one well one
thing i i often hear from people is this
idea of
you know i want to do this side hustle
therefore i'm going to quit my job and
i'm going to make it happen i would be
like hang on hang on like don't don't
quit your job until you've at least done
it for a little while yeah in in the
weekends and yeah weekends evenings um
but i guess these days it's it's sort of
become a bit unfashionable to talk about
doing the stuff on the weekends and
evenings and things and everyone's like
oh but like sustainability and like you
know work-life balance and mental health
and all that kind of stuff rightly so um
but i think there is still that balance
between like the people who sort of
succeed are the ones who do add in that
extra level of hustle extra level of
grind if you want to use those words
yeah i i think that you've all got to
you know to make something work there's
gonna have to be a period of time when
you have to go outside of your comfort
zone you're gonna have to work harder
than you you probably
healthfully should over a long period of
time but you're not doing that forever
so
um that was one year but i worked crazy
crazy amount of hours i'm doing a
full-time job with a three-hour drive
backwards and forwards to hire me one
hour and a half each way yeah and then
working in the evening so there was
crazy hours for a year big deal i you
know i felt like there was such an end
goal at the end of it was worth it yeah
and then when i started working at high
when i jacked the job i wasn't doing all
these evenings and weekends so there's
only one year
that was pretty easy in fact i end up
started working at two finishing at two
or three o'clock once somebody started
rolling in i was even finishing early to
make up for that previous year
then i suppose when i started sure that
that that that was tough when that
kicked off there was two to three years
of that when it that was crazy crazy
hours but now i'm 50 years old i've
given you example basically four years
in total out of 50 well i've worked
crazy hours that feels doable in my
house it feels doable um
so when you were when you were making
this money or attempting to make this
money from the affiliate stuff well why
you still had the job and you were
commuting three hours yeah what was it
that kept you going
in those those weekends and evenings
while you were knackered from a day of
work and driving back and back and forth
and you get on the computer you're like
what what's what's going through your
mind well this was that dream of not
being able to do that three hours we
never sit in that car yeah because this
was the day before um in the days before
podcast basically listen to radio radio
with adversity and driving backwards and
falls into london it's pretty you know
soul destroying and you think there's
this dream of i met these guys i
remember going to this event these guys
were there no brighter than me
i think one of them had an aston martin
one might have had a ferrari working
from home and you think there's that's a
dream so you just think if i just
knuckled down for that one year keeps
you going to do that and i thought and
also you know there's progress in that
year as well so during that year you
will see times when nothing's happened
and then she might have a little win a
little wind little win so you get like
little wins all the way through and yeah
clearly if i don't no money through that
whole time it literally just knuckled
down for a whole year nothing had
happened that probably would have been
tougher than i thought yeah but because
those wins and money's coming in at
different times
it brings it back to the yeah if i keep
going this i keep going i keep going
i'll get there eventually yeah yeah i
think in my life uh it would have been
around the same time like 2008 to
2010-ish
um i had like two distinct moments uh
one was when i first started doing
freelance web design and made like a few
dollars through a paypal account where i
lied about my age because i was like 14.
uh i
made like ten dollars through like
editing some like mysql code from some
of the websites i was like bloody hell i
can make money on the internet and the
second one was actually through
affiliates right um i i made this like
site that would get people to sign up
for love film affiliates yeah which is
like the pre-blockbuster pre-netflix era
and a friend of mine used his own
family's credit cards to sign up for
four free trials and i remember getting
a check in the mail for 50 quid which
was one of those like um electronic
checks where it's like tens of millions
zero millions zero tens of thousands
zero is like tens five i was like bloody
hell i made 50 quid and i
you know didn't have to work for it
directly yeah and it was just having
those two experiences of a making money
through selling my web design services
and then making money through building
this affiliate site that just gave me
such confidence that this is a thing you
can make money on the internet i can i
can make money through a business and i
think it was that sort of formative
experiences that meant when i was at uni
and started my first business that
actually worked i had the conviction and
the knowledge and the experience and
having failed it but a bunch of things
before to be able to make that work yeah
and i guess it kind of sounds similar so
similar experience to what you had yeah
i think that i'm i'm saying i've said it
before i think i'm particularly i don't
think i'm particularly brilliant at
anything i'm very good at marketing now
so i've done it for such a long period
of time i think naturally at school i
wasn't particularly brilliant anything
the beauty of like say working on uh
e-commerce or creating content or doing
whatever is if you put enough hours in
you can sometimes beat somebody with
more talent than you whereas like i
don't know football you got a football
pitch doesn't matter how much effort you
put in if you're not really good you're
not going to win right well it's
something like this you it can be just
through pure grind you can out you can
beat other people and at the time most
of the stuff that i was earning money
through required on seo the beauty of
seo is you can see rankings you can
check rankings and you know if i just do
that a little bit extra there i will get
a little bit of a bump up
you can see yourself eventually move
there'll be times when you get you go
down as well so there can be
disappointments but there's sometimes
when you get those you just think more
hours i can beat somebody who's they're
not gonna grind as much as i can i can
do more i'll work more and eventually
you could beat them so what sort of
stuff were you affiliating back in the
day this was vouch code websites so it's
very competitive space yeah so i
remember at the time i probably got in
it late-ish there was other ones that
already existed that were quite
established are we talking like uh hot
uk deals on those sorts of websites well
it's more to do like voucher codes hot
yoga deals with deals as well so didn't
really do that it's mostly voucher code
so i think it was my voucher codes dot
co dot ek vouchercodes.codyk they were
the big guns at the time and there's a
few others but there's always niches
within every category there's always a
niche you can go after okay so the niche
for me at the time was
um you know i'm pretty good at
researching so i dug into it as much as
i possibly can at the time the key the
key advantage for me was this that um
if you go to checkout pages when you
look at these codes people use the term
voucher codes but a lot of them don't
use the term voucher codes it will say
enter coupon code or enter discount code
or enter promotional code or enter a
promo code so it's actually quite
different quite a few different words
for the same thing
everybody chased after voucher codes
because that was the sort of generic
that people said but when i analyzed a
lot of people checkout pages i noticed
quite a few people using promotional
code so i registered
promotionalcodes.org.uk i think it was
the domain name that we had very snappy
title and um
but everybody's chasing after these
keywords over here so voucher codes and
discount codes and that was very
saturated but if you search for
promotional code so i don't know time
save tesco promotional code typically
the top ranking one didn't even have
promotional codes in the in the title
tag which is one of the key parts of a
page for seo so nobody's even going
after it wouldn't even optimize him for
that so that was the opportunity i saw
and so i used to you know work quite
hard to um get some rankings and i just
put all my i when you when you get links
you point them so most people point to
the home page i point them to a specific
product page so there's sort of deeper
pages so you've got a
site with sixty thousand merchants and
you can't point links to every single
page too many so i used to just start
with a very small site that had to say
five pages said links to each of those
five pages were those optimized title
tags and that would help me get rankings
for those it was hard work did it and
then like that's why i knew that if i
had more time i could do more merchants
and do them properly and just scale out
that way so are you creating the pages
manually on like wordpress or something
like that yeah yeah it's wordpress sure
and so you you find a website that maybe
sells five products you get the
affiliate thing through like trade
doubler or whatever whatever platforms
were up correct yeah and then you
manually create the pages and try it
well was it a case of trying to write a
blog post about the thing so pretty much
you've got to put some content in there
then you've got to go and spend time to
get the links into that there was lots
of tricks in the trailer work so whether
you did a link on a you'd find a forum
that would have track for followable
links on or
you probably might have paid someone to
do something you know at some point at a
time might be something going on there
so yeah i worked with a guy actually
interestingly i worked with the guy who
did the website so i wrote the content
and did the sort of the marketing or the
seo he did sort of tech side of stuff
and he was a guy i found a guy i think
it was on a forum and uh he was from
serbia worked with him straight for
three years i never met him never spoke
to him never zoomed him never skyped him
never did anything this was all done
through pretty much through base cam
which was like a task management tool
back in the day so he worked together
full time on that project
um yeah it's interesting i've never met
him still haven't met him today
yeah that's like uh remote work since
before like way before it was cool yeah
exactly the whole freelancer thing well
i think it came out the the
around the same sort of time it must
have been the four hour work week came
out around the same time one of the
primary things that i read at the time
sort of motivated as well to think right
yeah outsource outsource outsource do
student stuff you're good at and get rid
of all the other stuff
so that was the sort of key learning out
of that book and that was influential
yeah it's amazing how many people i
speak to who who've had four-hour work
week as like a an influential book in
there in their life
yeah temporary is very good it's very
well written and it makes you think
differently about how to do this whether
rather than a traditional way so yeah
i'd highly recommend it yeah yeah i i
discovered it when i was 17. it
completely blew my mind and just changed
the trajectory of my life in the sense
of like hey i'm doing this medical
school thing but i don't think i want to
rely on being a doctor forever for my
income therefore let's figure out this
passive income thing mini retirement
thing
it was just like such a such a paradigm
shift in in the way i saw the world
um well most have been brought up to be
you go to work you do a job you get paid
a salary but clearly that's not scalable
you know once you're your hours you're
going to work 40 hours a week or
whatever you get paid 40 hours that's
not scalable but the internet is like
not saying infinite but it's pretty big
so if you can work something to sell a
product or sell a service that's
scalable you don't even have to be the
best in the business because there's
billions of people out there in the
internet now you've only got yourself a
tiny tiny percentage of those really
really niche projects and um you can
have a really quite bigger business yeah
so at this point you're sort of mid 30s
you've worked as a marketing worked in
marketing for about 10 years at this
point if my math is correct and you
decided i need to work from home
therefore let's figure out these ways of
making money on the internet quit the
job uh six months like three months
later you're making more money than you
were in the job and then i think you you
started your first i guess i guess
official business in 2008. i was i was
reading 2008 let me see i'm just trying
to think of it that was yeah that was
promotionalcodes.org oh i see that was
that it was the other one that you sold
then yeah further down the line correct
what was that what was that like like
building it up and then selling the
business and like in this sort of genre
it was nice in the sense of that
business was solved the problem i had it
grew much bigger than i expected um so
in the final year so after three years
that was making more than two million
pounds per year
profit yeah and you know through
affiliate deals correct yeah through
manually making website pages and like
yep just through that website really
that one's in the website yeah there was
big money to be an affiliate business
was very big i think the affiliate has
changed dramatically since then i think
they do a lot of um i think some of the
the payments are much smaller now i
think lots of people don't don't do it
they might ban voucher code websites i
think that those days are over but um
it was uh it was highly profitable
obviously no new product
no customer service literally to create
a website get traffic to it redirect it
through um clicks to um the merchant and
you get paid either a bounty or
percentage of the sale yeah and how big
was your team then when you were doing
this sort of two million profit
i think right at the end there was four
of us maybe five okay
um but really it was just me and the guy
from serbia for the majority of the time
okay so
what was that
feeling like you know
you're you've been kind of grinding hard
at this job thing for the last 10 years
and now you you have this business which
is making two million plus a year yep
how did how did that feel at the time
can you remember um it feels quite um
surreal i watched your video yesterday
was talking about the money that you've
uh um through some of the sites that
you've done things and you just you sort
of you can't sort of quite believe it
sometimes
and um so i remember going down to the
pub was only about a year we don't think
it was and uh said they said he's how's
this going and i remember said to the
guy yeah at 60 60 grand he says pretty
good but i thought you were saying you
was earning really good money i said no
that's what i earned last month just
profit of 60 granny toys of the year
yeah so this was still quite early but i
mean in the final years it was like 250
000 pounds a month yeah profit so it
feels pretty unreal yep
my spending habits didn't even change
really great deal so i didn't actually
change you just you just knew that there
was a great deal of money there and um
but seo
being relying on seo can be quite risky
so i felt that it was um
it may not last i'd rather take the
chips off the table now if i can so we
ended up selling that business to an
american company for basic life changing
multiple of that amount
so i set myself up for for life so i was
basically 40 years old maybe just coming
up to 41 and had this amount of money
that would set me and my family up for
life yeah so then at that point what do
you do when you're like you've you've
taken the money box you've you've
completed the game in that sense yeah um
i was speaking to oliver cookson founder
of myprotein a few a few months ago and
he was saying that because he lives in
monaco and he was talking about how
there's a lot of people he meet who get
sort of tens of millions in the bank and
then they're like oh you know that y'all
that's hundreds of millions and end up
doing this thing of chasing more and
more money but it doesn't sound like
that's the the direction that you went
i did probably what a lot of people did
i took some time out
to try and suss out what i wanted to do
i didn't didn't certainly wasn't uh it
wasn't it wasn't tens of millions like
i'm not allowed to say the amount but it
was less than 10 million and um
so i couldn't buy you i probably could
borrow you but i couldn't really buy you
or anything like that and i'm i'm sort
of the person thinks well it's got to
last the rest of your life right i'm 40
i could live for another 40 years yet so
i'm only halfway there so i can't spend
all so we stayed in the same house took
some time out i had a young baby at the
time decided to um
spend some time doing that and trying to
think
and i think i said you briefly earlier
before it's very tempting when you're
working really hard oh my god that's the
dream i'd love to take some time off i'd
love to see on the beach for six months
but i think when people talk about work
like work life balance i think it works
both ways i think
people typically mean work life balance
is you shouldn't be working all the time
you should have a balance with with uh
leisure time i think the the reverse is
true that if you have too much level
type leisure time and no work i think
that can be detrimental to probably your
health or your mental health
so i decided i needed to do a bit of
work
but i didn't want to go back and do
the extreme of work again so i didn't
want a full-time job i wanted a let's
call it a lifestyle business
uh three days a week would be optimum
so i thought what am i interested in
what do i want to do and uh
and uh so the business that she'll
eventually span out was a business that
i started which is a company called body
hack so i started that with the
intention of being a lifestyle business
that would keep me going forever i
didn't want to start something there was
no there was no intention to flip it
sell it or anything like that i wanted
to start something i was going to be
interested in so keep me busy uh for a
long time interesting
interesting i was speaking to another um
internet friend on a zoom call a few
days ago who
who's like 28 sold his startup for like
50 million or something like that and he
was also being like yeah you know i took
two months off i realized [ __ ] i don't i
don't have time off
i want to actually actually do something
yeah um i don't think that's so
interesting because i think people who
have not it's that classic thing if you
haven't hit that point you think ah i'd
want to chill on the beach forever and
kind of tim ferriss talks about this at
the end of the four-hour workweek that
you get this void this existential void
of like what the hell do i now do with
the rest of my life yeah and i think
some people go back and do what they
used to do in which maybe full-time
start another business businesses can be
really hard they can be really drained
on you i i didn't really intend to do
something that was going to be as um as
demanding what she i genuinely wanted to
do three days a week i think if you've
got three days work that you're really
passionate about you really like doing
yeah and you've got three or four days
that you can spend doing other stuff i
think that has got to be the best i
think doing i don't know what elon musk
does you know surely he's going to look
back one day oh my god i've never lived
a life i've just been working all the
time i don't think that's good for you i
don't think sitting on beach is good i
think something between the two is good
nice so
what was body hack how did that happen
uh so body hack was um i think at the
times i had a bit of time ahead i
thought i'd try and get himself a bit
fitter i know
one of your goals this year was to do
that get a bit more fit yeah yeah and um
so i thought right i'm interested in
this went online and it pissed me off a
bit that there's so much
i've seen fake news out there but so
many people was trying to sell something
and giving you these massive promises
about how if you did this is going to
work and i was just very skeptical and i
just felt
it felt a bit grubby to me some of the
stuff that was going on i thought i
didn't like this i thought what i'm
going to do
i'm going to speak to some experts find
out how to do this properly and then
make
a website where it's evidence-based so
if you want to put muscle on we're going
to put people through different programs
different
eating plans
photographs measurements record it every
week so at the end of it we would have
these different
programs where you would actually be
able to see which ones work and you go
right i want those results if i do
exactly what he does i know it's going
to work because i can see it uh if i
want to lose weight if i want to they'll
be vegan different all these different
different things and goals and things
you want to achieve so i was a guinea
pig for one of those
um the pt i saw him three times a week
so no more exercise than normal three
hours a week
but the difference was he gave me a very
strict meal plan which i followed to the
letter for three months and it wasn't i
wasn't starving myself i was eating
three meals a day three snacks a day
but i was cooking it all from scratch
and weighing everything i was like
well calorie perfect hopefully i weighed
everything very accurately so within
three months i went from
uh
21 body fat down to 11 body fat so i was
41 years old yeah and it was the leanest
i've ever been here as long as i've ever
been and you know like you know the sort
of fact you can pinch off there that was
pretty much what was here
um i put a bit more on recently because
i've been trying to bulk out a little
bit because i was like i got down like
very light i'm a five foot eleven and i
think i got down to about 11 stone 10
and a half which is probably too light
for what i should have been but it was
just like i just stripped this body fat
off i'd never done that before i've been
going to the gym for the last 10 years
and never got the same results it's very
very clear yeah in that three months i'd
achieved more than i had in the previous
10 years in terms of body composition
and it's because i weighed on the food
so it just shows you you are what you
eat
um
so friends um and i started that
business i got some traction but the
consistent feedback was that this is too
hard to follow i can't stop at 11
o'clock and cook an egg and some
broccoli i can't stop at one o'clock and
cook this food
so
um so made me think i this is there's
something very special here
but
what the problem is it's not convenient
enough how do i make this much more
convenient easy to follow
and a protein shake was uh the product i
was using for afternoon snack it was the
most easy and convenient meal of the day
effectively
but you can't live off protein why can't
you take all these central nutrients put
into a single product have the same
convenience of a protein shake but
you can live off it if you chose to or
replace the meals that you have a
problem with so that was the the genesis
of fuel
it was soylent i think back in the day
so interestingly how does that come onto
the scene because yeah i remember that
was a thing in like the silicon valley
kind of people and a lot of people
taking the piss out of it and yeah yeah
so the interesting thing was i wasn't
aware of sun at this time yeah
we eventually looked so this must have
been 2012 i think what i'm talking about
body hacks something like that 2012 2013
i don't oh sorry somebody here can
google it and find out exactly when they
launched i'm not sure but i wasn't aware
of it so this was this is me trying to
solve my specific problem at the time
we launched in
2015 june
so by the time we'd launched or before
we'd launched i realized that soylent
existed
there was another brand in uh the
netherlands that was doing something
similar and
there might have been a german one as
well
so i was sort of
a little bit annoyed that there was
other things out there similar but
competition happens in every market
right so somewhere that wasn't that
bothered and there was nobody directly
selling in the uk at the time so we
launched
we did get a good um
good launch we got quite a lot of
national pr it's quite a novel type of
product
so
yeah fair play to everybody else i
didn't really mind interesting yeah
because i remember when i first started
taking huel people like what the hell is
this heal thing i was like it's it's
kind of the uk version of soylent and at
the time so when it was in the news
people knew what it was
but i found myself like someone asked
why did you take or like what is here i
was like i was a uk version of soylent
and they were like what soylent i was
like oh interesting i think he'll as a
brand at least in the uk i don't know
about internationally is now so
recognizable and like no one really
knows what at least at least here anyone
really knows what soylent is i don't
know if that's kind of the vibe that
you've gotten as well yeah i think we're
globally number one now in terms of
volume of sales i think that we i think
we've done a very good job in terms of
execution brand
service yeah um i think our nutritionals
are very strong i think our product
ingredient is very i think we do things
really really well um you know i think
they've had a few problems i think
interestingly the founding team are no
longer there and i think that it just
shows that founder led business can be
very strong and it can be very important
you know you think that we said elon
musk you think of steve jobs i think
sometimes having the founder a company
even if they're just an adviser i think
is really key
um
but anyway i i don't know exactly what
they did wrong but yeah they don't seem
to have um fulfilled their potential
yeah their founder john was actually a
student on my youtuber academy really a
few months ago so he's not he's now got
a youtube channel where he's actually
making really strong strong videos
analyzing businesses and stuff like that
yep um but it seems like he's he's
living the dream now doing a good thing
i think they were very young guys going
back to sing about young guys starting
businesses um
maybe they just got i don't know
distracted they wanted to do something
else and wait to make videos i don't
know what it was
so okay so what
what was happening at hill from like
2012 to 2015 when you sort of
in in that sort of pre-launch period
okay what does that look like you have
this idea yeah like
where do you even begin okay so
um so body hack i ended up burning some
money in a body hack which is the money
and i think um my my my ex-wife she
said she was a bit annoyed with me but
because i was sort of it felt like i
didn't need to work so why do you need
to work why would you do this i think
it's important for me to do it
so
um
i think that um
i was quite cautious with yours i didn't
want to go and burn any more money
exactly two in a row me playing around
just burning the family money yeah so i
was very cautious with it and i spent a
lot of time it's one when you get
certain ideas in your head you can't get
them out they keep coming back no matter
how much you try so i ended up thinking
about it a lot spent a ton of time on
the first port of call was trying to
find nutritionist to talk through the
nutritionals of it so i found james
collier who ended up being our
co-founder
james collier was actually gordon's
first personal trainer
like 10 years ago
we were talking about him earlier
no what was the muscle top muscle talk
that's it
from breast competition
interesting
so you found james collier the
nutritionist family changed collier so
we did the nutrition was really quite
quick he did a
report you know i had to find him i had
to interview a few people i spoke to a
guy in australia to go in
us and then eventually spoke to james so
all these things takes time because i
wasn't cause i was trying to sort of get
body hat going as well you see so i
thought it wasn't fully committed to to
shield at this stage but it just the
more i thought about it more i saw the
benefits because the fact that it's in a
powdered form mean that there's no water
no water means no bacteria no no um
preservatives needed
uh you don't need a big packaging
minimal packaging fact that we made it
vegan means better for the planet
there's no waste because you shouldn't
throw food away lots of foods thrown
away so it just solved so many problems
i couldn't get out my head
um so i had to come up with the name
names take a long time names are super
super important yeah where did he'll
come from so hule is obviously human
food put together
and um
things do take a long time so i must
have i looked at
all sorts of languages looked at all
sorts of different ways but i think
sometimes creating a unique word that's
never been used before makes your life a
lot easier yeah so i think
i think it's been quite influential in
terms of our success i think it it looks
like a logo it looks right yeah and i
think that it's distinctive and i think
the beauty of having a name that of
course it does exist i think there's
some there are some shows in the world
some people that call you certainly man
first name so it does exist but there
was a lot competition in terms of uh you
know google if you search for it it
doesn't mean anything in people's heads
so you can give it meaning like it's an
empty vessel yeah and so if you ever
kind of come up with a name i think
trying to come up with a unique name is
quite hard so maybe just write down a
list of the names that are associated
with your product yeah
and you can cut them up and then bash
them together and you might find a word
appears in front of you and that's sort
of what i did with the tool so it's it's
a it's a fuel for humans
and you cut it up and you just bash it
together and it creates a new word so i
think it's a um
a wise thing there's a book that i i
read or read many times which is called
um i think it's 22 immutable laws of
market i've heard really good things
about it i haven't read it yet it's very
short it's about 80 pages the guy makes
so much sense when you read it it's
quite an old book so some of the
references are out of date yeah um but
it's uh seven pounds on amazon just buy
it if you're gonna if you want to start
a business or get anything to do with
marketing i think
i think it's just as valuable as my
marketing degree to be honest i could
have saved three years of my life by
just reading that i think it's really
really good and in there he does talk
about the value of names how important
they are you know you need a word that
you can say you can spell you can repeat
to other people
if you can't it's making your life a lot
harder yeah and you want something that
visually looks right so hill was not the
front runner at one point but when the
guy made the logo it just looked right
as well so there's a visual sort of
aesthetic of a name as well how it looks
on the page so we just talked about baby
names a second ago
and this uh that's that sort of thing
can be important yeah and i think that
name is the one thing that will probably
stay with you forever right so if you
think about logos do change people
change their logos your ceo's gonna
change um your staff are going to change
your product is going to change but the
one thing's going to remain constant
forever if you think about long term
would be the name so i don't say you
spend years on it but spend some uh
valuable time on it make sure you get
the best name you can possibly get yeah
yeah i'm
i feel like the the the thing with the
name i've i've had so many idea ideas
for things over the years which have
then been like ah
once i think of a good name then i'll
make this happen right and i feel like
there is a danger especially when you're
young and just starting out a first
business or a second business where
statistically it's pretty unlikely to
succeed like overthinking on the name
front over thinking oh we need a logo we
need we need a website we need a
business card and then let's not worry
about the product until further down the
line and then a lot of people i think
get stuck in this cycle of
procrastination correct um but remember
i didn't think much on the first one so
my first company was promotional code
that was sort of a slightly different
way so i think there's two
for me there's been two types of
businesses there's one is to make to has
a goal of making money and yeah you
might optimize that in a certain
slightly different way than say the way
cure's been optimized and what we've
been trying to do here yeah so if i
tried to start huel in 20 um
2008 when i started my first business
that would not achieve the goal i would
have run out of money because it took me
two years two two and a half years to
get to market yeah i would have run out
of money and i never would have achieved
that goal yeah so you need to write down
what the goals are what you're trying to
do and how quick you need to do it so i
need to make money within six months
and so she would have failed right and
we wouldn't be sat here today so i think
i need to understand what you're trying
to do do that
and there may be slightly different
things i'm saying that we'll achieve
that goal and achieve this goal over
here
how did you get healed.com surely it
wasn't just available this is like 20 14
times
all these four letters were just gone it
wasn't available and the guys the guy's
negotiation tactics were very clever i
think he sold domains for a living yeah
i sort of uh i think at the time i think
it was about
six thousand dollars and um i got sure
i think i launched with fuel dot emmy
that was that was free there was a few
that were free so just like one that was
free
when you started getting a little bit of
traction i thought no i want the the
main domain i think qr.codyk wasn't
available.com i want to go for congress
i want this big global business so let's
go after that one i think it was six
thousand and uh i just got to touch and
said well what doesn't mean anything you
haven't sold it you've had it for 10
years surely
i'll give you five for or something like
that and he went well it's six thousand
and six thousand for seven days
seventh day passed i went back to him
and uh i said
you still want to sell it goes what is
seven thousand pounds now what do you
mean the price has gone up surely come
down we're negotiating here we don't put
the price up he goes well the seven
thousands for seven days
his value for seven days or something
like that and he did this several times
until he got to over ten
and uh
i left it for a few months before i
could get i don't need i don't need it
and then then she'll start taking off a
bit more
i do need this now i went back to him
and he said it's twelve and a half
thousand now and kept on putting the
price up i've never had this before and
i thought i'm not i never paid full
price for anything i'm not paying full
price so in the end i said so look this
is my final offer
uh i'm you can't sell this to anybody
else you know just once all right it
doesn't mean anything to anybody else
you're never gonna sell you've had it so
long this is my final final i'm telling
you i'm not coming back ever again it's
ten or nothing and i think it took the
ten
that's good negotiations
yeah these like these domain squatters
are so annoying um there's so many so
many things that i wanted to do with
domains and then the dot com is not
available because it's like owned by
some squatter yeah so someone even did
um a clever thing so you know so you
know the dot eth domains now with the oh
in in the crypto world uh like dot eth
okay and someone has has registered my
name dot dot i'm like god damn it and
he's i i i looked at his thing and he's
you know it's his uh uh his um
equivalent to who
uh and he's just take gone through
youtube and podcasts he's got like tim
ferriss.if he's got like lewis hoes he's
got all of the big podcast names the big
youtubers he's just squatting on those
domain names knowing that they might
become valuable there's so many of these
extensions now you don't need that
particular one you could get one with
your name on i don't know
whatever it is yeah i bought my.com
like around the time when i was 15 and i
was like at the time i was like oh this
is a it's a bit of a [ __ ] move
um but now it's it's coming quite handy
yeah um so you got heal.com after a
bunch of negotiating um you got james
collier the nutritionist coming together
what
how
how how did how did it then sprout from
from the you having a chat with james
okay
so i obviously put the name together
i've got the logo i uh started putting
the website together put on shopify
which we've been seeing
with ever since they've been good to us
um
and started writing the copy trying to
get the brand positioning the brand feel
and feel trying to get all those things
together so i could do all of that so i
did
everything i possibly could the one
thing i couldn't do myself was make the
product even i can make it my kitchen in
like
not that long a blender yeah you can
make it but to make it a commercial
scale to food grade yeah was a different
kettle of fish okay so like how how do
you make it in your kitchen like if you
if you wanted to just make it by
yourself do you do you like buy
carbohydrates
you can go on and you can buy individual
component parts okay and you can put it
together one thing you can't do very
easily but you can even unless you've
got really really accurate scales would
be the vip blend okay so most of the
vitamins i think majority of vitamins
ensure will come from the the the
natural sources so the oats are very
vitamin and mineral rich the p protein
will have some in it flaxseed will have
some in it but you would have to top up
with certain vitamins to make the thing
nutritiously complete i guess it's hard
to like kind of just buy a powder with
vitamin a
you can from certain places yeah but the
weight of it sometimes depends on the
quantity but you were talking about
sometimes such small amounts you need
very very accurate scales you can do in
a kitchen in theory um
but commercial scale the strange thing i
found with the food business is in
typically
food manufacturers is quite a closed
world
they
love don't even have websites a lot of
them are quite secretive because say
you've got a say you're making a really
good um a drink or something you might
not want anybody to know where it's made
because then people can go there and get
it made and you don't want them to know
how to make it because then that's an
extra competition in the market so not
many people talk about where it's made
quite hard to find them a lot of them
don't even have their own websites and
also when you ring up and say i'm
starting a business can i make a small
order
no because factories are set up to make
things make things very effectively and
very efficiently
at scale so if you have to stop a line
change a line to do a small batch run
they're not really that interested the
feedback i got after a lot of work after
speakers a lot of people making a lot of
phone calls was they don't want to speak
to you because they've heard this so
many times the startup's going to come
along they're going to place an order
for a few thousand pounds they're going
to cause them a load of time and effort
to do that a few thousand pounds and
they won't be able to sell it and
they'll never come back they've just
wasted their time so they're not really
interested i'd rather deal with bigger
players so really really hard to get it
live and i got let down a lot of times
and the most frustrating one was i
actually finally got a big multinational
company to agree to do this so i knew
they could do it
uh the guy said he was uk sales manager
at time he said he was going to do it
and they basically strung me along for
about four months and i'd already been
a year 18 months in at this stage
i was scared of burning money like i
said about money before
and um
uh
and then i was getting frustrated what
are we getting when i'm getting the
product when i'm getting the product and
um
finally on this fourth month after he
said he was going to do what's going to
do he's going to do all the way through
he's just sent me an email called no
phone call no nothing said we've decided
i'm not going to do it um and at that
point i'd i think i had enough i said
right that's it i'm done
um
and um
then i had a few beers that i woke up in
the morning we're not not gonna let him
not gonna let him spoil this whole thing
i put a lot of time and effort into this
so i went back on the phone the
following day
and ended up speaking to the the guys we
still work with today they were a small
small business down in devon
and they've grown with us so six years
later six nine years later we're still
working with them today they've grown
really big off the back of us and we've
grown big as well
how did you know this was going to work
did you have like
did you make the stuff in you in your
own kitchen to be to test the concept
faster like yeah yeah so i think
my my very simple logic was this i don't
think i'm
completely weird
and i was using it and i found there was
value in the product it was saving me
time i knew i was getting very good
quality nutrition and i was using this
my very basic logic was
the internet's a big place
surely i can find a thousand people this
thousand true fan concept that kevin
kelly came up with i'm sure i can find a
thousand people slightly different he
said a thousand people a year i weigh a
thousand people a month surely i can
find a thousand people a month that'll
pay 45 pounds for this product that's 45
000 pounds a month 600k a year whatever
um
make some profit out of that and i've
got a nice lifestyle business to keep me
happy not to overwhelm me with work but
to keep you to do something that i would
be proud of and a good quality product
that will
make some people's lives better okay
so i thought surely i can do that surely
i can find enough people that would that
understand the same thing yeah yeah i
thought yeah
yeah of course i could do that
and that was it that was that was the
original sort of principle and goals so
you'd kind of done the proof of concept
in your own kitchen and be like yep this
is actually quite tasty it's
nutritionally complete this works for me
now let's scale and you eventually found
this company in devon yeah how did you
find them like what was that google i
think google google if we're starting
any business google's definitely your
friend what do you google like food
manufacturer right yeah everything every
keyword you can think of food
powder um even some of the ingredients
you might look for yeah
then you might speak to one person you
might land on a few people then you
speak to them they say no we can't do
this and he said do you know anybody you
can they might point your direction you
go that is a dead end keep going back
yeah
so lots of googly okay so you found
these guys in devon small business
um were they like taking a big risk and
working with you initially or what was
that relationship i think the answer
originally was no from them yeah they
said no i'm not interested i said come
on you know i'm just gonna you know
i don't know how i convinced them but i
think i convinced them and said look i
think originally i think i wanted to
order two and a half thousand pounds
worth and i think they said no it's not
worth our time i said okay so
that was in the phone call we sort of
put it out and i thought about it i
thought no he's
i think that made the tone his voice was
it wasn't an immediate no there may be a
little pause i thought right we're
nearly there so i went back and i said
what about if i double the order on
order 5 000 pounds worth
and um i think at that point he said yes
okay
so now you have 5 000 pounds worth of
powder like is it like in your in your
kitchen in your bedroom at this point
like garage
yeah so all launched out of my garage
right um i can remember the early days i
sort of
had pallet loads of this stuff boxes and
uh i got a couple of those like i don't
know what they're called um carpenters
horses you know like the table things
like that palette on top and i can
remember i packed all the early boxes
the website was live we went live in
june 17th 2015.
i packed all the early orders
and um
again i would advise people if you ever
start in a business try and do as much
as you possibly can yourself i don't
mean forever but going back to the tim
ferriss concept you should outsource
stuff but i think the best thing to do
is do it yourself first so then you know
how it should be done yeah so when you
outsource it to somebody you can tell
them exactly how you want it done yeah
so i when i sort of packed the boxes or
sort of looked at it it felt a little
bit was the word
a little bit average so i i then got a
um well those rubber stamps made so
instead of getting loads of printed
boxes i just made the rubber stamps and
then pressed it on the tops so that you
know you get that sort of like slightly
rusty looking logo it looks nice yeah
hand stamped so you showed a little bit
of carrying attention it's something you
know do things that can't scale um
uh i
printed these sort of big sort of thank
you cards it was sort of some sort of
inspirational quotes on hand signed them
and numbered every single one i put a
t-shirt in there which we still think
about today
and um packed them all nicely and sent a
load off to the press sent a load off to
obviously the initial customers but i
hand-packed them with sort of you know
care and attention so when we scaled up
i could then pass on something so i want
it done exactly like this yeah
so what happened then so this was june
june 2015. you launched was there you
sort of uh fanfare out of the gates what
what was this
[Music]
um but it was sort of quite exciting i
think we got two orders before the day
we actually launched was interesting i'd
mentioned it on a forum oh sorry on the
facebook group and a couple of guys came
in and just bought it so i thought
something interesting i mean i've
gone live this was a test site and they
bought something so got got orders
immediately
and this is something that really hard
to know when you're starting a company
there's definitely been companies have
been flatlined for a very long time and
hockey's dick up
but i've had three companies now
effectively the first one just went
straight like that and pretty much
forever
the body hat company went like this
got some attraction we got i think i've
got on hacker news on day one remember
yeah yeah i think
so i've gotten you know why combinations
hacking news so i caused you i think
about 75 000 visits in the first day or
something yeah so i've got those visits
and got quite a few orders on day one
but that spike didn't last obviously and
went back down again and then the
feedback from the initial customers were
they were pretty much on it was a
subscription business sort of
unsubscribed fairly quickly after the
first month so i thought this is this is
gone like that and it was hard whereas
um first business went like that and she
also went like that
so i'm not saying you should give up but
there is an argument at some stage
you've got to decide when you're going
to give on something
or do you keep sort of just trucking
ahead for years and years and years
really tricky one but we did get initial
traction straight away initial orders
national press i paid an agency
because in back in the day when i was
doing
voucher codes i was jealous of one of
the the competitors who kept on getting
quite good national press so i remember
looking who was their pr agency and i
remembered it so when i launched my
business
three years later i thought i'm going to
go to that agency so i found found that
agency at peer agency here said right on
a three month contract 5k a month for
the first three months uh that's all i
want so i want some press logos because
when you're buying a food product you've
never tasted
is not traditional food in the way you'd
expect it to look and you've got to give
me 45 pounds up front
um i thought it's quite a hard ask so i
thought if i've got some press logos it
will become more trustworthy you know
you're going to put this thing inside
your body if it's been seen on all the
national newspapers so i said goal is
first three months i want national news
and i want quotes out of all of these
these uh national press you know times
telegraph daily mail etc etc
and they did that and
orders came in
and then a few months later started
turning on performance ads and then
performance ads then you can just scale
that range you just turn the dial up
each month to get that nice growth you
have and connect it to an american
express account so you get like loads of
miles
but we did do that at one stage yeah
they're not as easy to use you think oh
really yeah i heard that um
how did you arrive at the 45 quid price
point
interestingly
i did the maths on it and because it's
quite heavy product
you know this has always been something
we've also had a problem with but
because we force you to buy two two
pouches at once people go why can't you
buy one well if you buy one the price is
gonna shoot up in terms of cost per meal
because the delivery charge is spread
over two yes and cost per meal is the
number i always look at be like ah yeah
and you know 2.83 that's that's actually
pretty cheap
yeah so it felt like the optimum way for
me to yeah it's quite a big ask but i do
remember i can't remember who it was i
think it was one of our non-execs um
who i started working with the guy who
helped me sell my first business he did
say it's much easier to bring your price
down is put your price up so go in at a
price which is as fair as you can but if
there's a if there's a
i think the tempting thing for for
entrepreneurs or people starting
businesses is
if i set it cheaper i'll get more
customers yeah yeah you might do but it
might make your business much harder
you've got to sell a lot more to make
profit
so
you know if you if you if you don't ask
you don't get so maybe just start a
little bit higher than what you might
because there might be loads of costs
you're not aware of which is very true i
mean over here's life i think we've been
profitable four years out of six
and um you know we we're you know a big
business now and our profit is still
you know relatively small as an ebitda
percentage
because we're still in a growth phase
when you're growing there's lots of
things you've got to spend money and you
may not think about so don't just work
out on just your basic margin as it is
yeah what you're you could sell out like
don't cut yourself too short so that's
how i came up with that price oh
interesting yeah that's something i i
hear from like new entrepreneurs a lot
where they're like i've got this idea
i'm like okay cool what else is in the
market and how are you going to be
better than them oh yeah we're going to
undercut them like oh
yeah okay this is it's gonna be it's
gonna be tricky um i remember when when
i when i got into med school
basically the standard business that
anyone getting into med school who has
an entrepreneurial spirit to them is let
me make courses teaching other people
how to get into med school right and so
every year there is always five to ten
new businesses that start up yeah we'll
undercut the competition right and every
year there's five or ten businesses that
fold because they realize that actually
selling courses for 30 quid for a whole
day is actually unsustainable when you
have all these other costs that add up
yeah um and it's the companies that tend
to actually go in at a more reasonable
or higher price point for a few hundred
pounds for the day with scholarships for
for people from whatever backgrounds um
those are the ones that seem to survive
longer and the strategy of undercutting
the competitors i think it's very hard
to make it work unless you're like
amazon scale i guess
yeah
pricing is super hard to get right
there's definitely an argument sometimes
that um
you know if i was going to make a
judgement call on say you got two
courses one's 10 pounds and one's 200
pounds which one's better
people are going to think that you know
lvmh is one of the richest companies in
the world cylinder
luxury brands at crazy crazy prices with
huge huge margins on them and then
sometimes that makes them more desirable
you know if you're trying to sell a
watch even you know most people can't
judge whether the watch is good quality
or not but if you charge 50 000 pounds
for it you think that must be really
good that's really desirable right so
the pricing is hard to get right it
can't be just done purely on margin
can't be just done purely on um how much
money you need to take in to make the
profit you particularly want um you
can't just judge it against competitors
so i remember when starbucks first
launched in the uk i think starbucks was
like two or three quid of coffee and the
default was 50p or whatever for a cup of
coffee and you know in styrofoam cups
the real horrible ones so
sometimes if you've got a premium
product you're in a better position it
sounds crazy we talked about red bull
earlier they're 1.50 or whatever it is
whereas um you know you can buy
alternatives much much much cheaper so
pricing is quite hard it's definitely an
art as well as the science so did you
get pushback on the pricing as uh was it
like like oh this is kind of boring on
expensive when you have that 45 quid we
get it all the time for it's expensive
but i actually said i think i think uh a
meal is one pound fifty right one pound
51 i think is a powder meal so
for 400 calories if you want to go and
buy a sandwich from certain sandwich
shops in london it could be really
expensive five six pounds i suppose so
it it it depends and you know we want it
to be affordable but we don't want to
sell something you know cheap and nasty
want to sell a high quality premium
product and when you think about all the
stuff that comes with it you know you
get free delivery you get a free t-shirt
that's worth 20 pounds you get a free
shake which is worth 10 pounds you know
it's uh well packaged premium
ingredients compared to some
the the nutritionals are very strong you
get uh very good customer service you
know everything the whole thing together
i think is in really good value for
money and even on a you know cost per
meal basis yes you do have to buy in
sort of a bulk but still it's relatively
affordable so
it's it's just very it's very difficult
to please everybody all the
time um
what was the rationale behind the
t-shirt t-shirt and the continuing to
include the t-shirt um
the original rationale i probably can't
even remember that so long ago i think i
just felt like there was something i
wanted to give
um i think this is them
uh there's a book on the principles of
persuasion
i
think
yeah i think it's seven principles and
one of those is you give something to
somebody so i think the classic example
they give is um you know when you go to
a restaurant when they want the bill at
the end they give you some sweets or
some chocolates i think mcdonald's have
a happy meal where they give kids the
the free toy i think if you give
something there's been loads of science
done so if you give something they feel
obliged to give something back yeah so
it's part of the art of persuasion and i
think i remember reading that book i
remember that and i thought
okay i'm trying to persuade people to do
something that put their hand in their
pocket never tried this product it's a
food product they can't eat they can't
sample it before we can't really send
you a sample it's difficult to do
therefore it's an added value i'd much
rather added ad added value rather than
give a discount yeah so the price i
could buy the t-shirt for will will be
more than the discount i could possibly
give you
and it helps spread the brand name right
this is one of the key things when
you're launching something new how do
you get your your brand awareness up
yeah you can spend money on it but the
beauty of a t-shirt is you could wear it
for years you could wear it hundreds of
times and thousands of people could see
that brand name it's quite well fitting
as well and i hug the biceps slightly
it's not too much it like it kind of
makes me feel a bit more hench when i
wear it yeah so i've i uh you know i've
done this product you know the whole
fuel to be something i want to be proud
of so i i very conscious about the
products that i choose and um
the early t-shirt was an off-the-shelf
one but then about two years in we went
to a full custom one we spent nearly a
year developing that t-shirt believe it
or not and uh the attention to detail on
it i think is very good so yeah we do
spend a lot of time to make sure and uh
you know i could probably argue i could
really justify i would have an argument
somebody said this probably one of our
lowest cpa um
advertising techniques
difficult to prove or almost improv
impossible to prove but i could argue
that i mean i've seen loads of people
wearing wearing wearing the t-shirt and
i've been in the market i i i keep on
trying different brand t-shirts to wear
and the the issue with like for example
the uniqlo ones is that they shrink
after two watches but i still have my
heel black one from like 2018 because
it's just a great t-shirt to wear like i
probably wouldn't wear in public much
but like it's wear around the house to
wear to the gym it's just a nice fitting
t-shirt that doesn't shrink yeah and i
guess that comes from the attention to
detail that you guys correct
so in the first year i read somewhere
that you did about a million in sales
okay so
i think we've changed our year ends a
little bit so it's hard for me to
remember but
if i remember the original ones in the
first six months i do remember this very
clearly we launched in june so by
christmas that year i think we've done
about 750 000 pounds of the sales
and then the following
uh calendar year i think we did about
five million i think it was and then
then it was 14 million the following
calendar year that's in calendar years
not the official numbers okay
um
what was
what was the team like at the time like
how did how did things grow teamwise
okay team was very scrappy to start with
yeah the interesting thing is um okay
when you're starting a business
in the corporate world most people have
got very you know small jobs
sorry uh very defined yeah narrowly
defined correct yeah when you're
starting a business half time you don't
know what you do need so what you want
is very open-minded people who are
willing to muck in and wear many hats so
what i did originally was again keeping
keep cost really low i got i think most
of our early employees first few were
basically straight grads these are
people who came out of university never
done a job before and i wanted to do
things differently i wanted to have a
different culture and i wanted to not do
it the standard corporate way so i
wanted people that were easier to mold
and people who had no preconceptions
about what they should be doing or any
arrogance about this is
beneath me because you would have to
sweep the floor sometimes you'd have to
do pack boxes you'd have to do quite
menial jobs sometimes and then then you
got switched straight away to dealing
with
buying product or
dealing with the finance problem or
something like that you had to change
and shop and change real quick so that
was the the initial initial team of sort
of people straight out of university and
most of them are still there today so
now you have like 200 something people
over 200 people now yeah what was that
like or how did your head count change
over time can you can you remember what
the rough
i can't remember really i think very
crudely very very crudely you could
probably argue around the same sort of
number of people per million one person
per million
so in the first year say one person
following year we're doing five million
might be in five or six people following
us 14 might have been up to 14 to 20
people something like that that's still
like very small considered uh
scrappy yeah
yeah very scrappy to start with okay
because you don't know it's very hard
like i said going back to this fear of
burning money yeah i wanted to do things
really as best as i could but i didn't
want to go and scale up with loads of um
you know sea sweet people yeah in the
early days when you don't know because
an early stage business is um is like um
you know
i was talking about babies earlier
because my my partner's pregnant but i
you know but
early companies are like babies they
could it's horrible to say they could
die at any stage right very very um
they need a lot of care and attention so
it's high risk to go and take a load of
people from very senior jobs trying to
attract them into your business you
think oh my god imagine if the business
went under they've lost their job and
they can't pay their mortgage so it was
very scrappy in the first couple of
years
i think it's about the
second and a half maybe third year we
moved from
real temporary
service officials the sort of ones with
the blue carpet tiles and the sort of
like white walls in between real
unbranded office we actually bought an
office across the uh the car park and we
fully branded up and that was the sort
of moment when you went from a flaky
business that felt like it could go
under any stage to a real business and
at that stage that's when we started
scaling up the people a lot faster oh
interesting can you remember what the
what the main challenges were when you
had like 15 to 20 people this is the
position that i've been at the women 15
20 people we've talked about recruitment
earlier so i think recruitment is always
a problem in every business at every
stage
you know when you're when you're really
young you don't want to take really good
experience people in
as you get bigger you want to do that
but then you need to attract people in
but because you're not so early stage
some people might think it's not as
exciting as your sort of later stage
there's always there's always a reason
why it's hard to do and getting the
right people to move to your offices
that may not be in the same area they
are because talent is sort of equally
distributed in my eyes so to get talent
you might have to persuade people we've
had people move from scotland we've had
people move from overseas to come and
join us so to get the right talent can
be really hard i think it's always hard
whether you're 15 or 200 people i think
it's always hard and what are the
challenges like
how how do the challenges change over
time as you go sort of from 20 to 50 to
100. like i'm just trying to get a
feeling of
what that experience is like having
never done it before really
i'm i'm not sure
how much it changes because while you're
in it it always feels the same sort of
level of challenge if that makes sense
yeah
so i know in the podcast she was talking
to ben about um
you know i think he was saying that even
people who are running big multi-billion
pound business are sort of winging it to
a certain extent
i totally agree i think there is uh you
know you know your company my company
never existed before so you could read a
book but that's based on how to run
another company yeah so it's a different
situation you're in so every company i
think is unique every time is unique
we've never lived in this time before
we've never just come out coming out of
covid this has never happened ever
before quite like this therefore every
time every moment every company is
unique at that moment in time so you are
always winging it because you've always
got a different challenge that's never
quite existed before my uh general
manager angus he he asked the other day
as we were driving back from gymshark
i'd be like hey you know gymshark is a
pretty big brand like you know have you
thought about you know where we're at 17
people right now we're at like four four
million revenue whatever have you
thought about kind of beyond 10 million
20 million 50 million like could we
actually impact like some millions more
people than we're thinking
are our ambitions too small and in my
mind i was thinking
yeah but i feel like every time we add
more people the stress level goes up a
little bit um
has that been true in your experience or
is there a point at which you're like
actually adding an extra 30 people
doesn't significantly change your
personal stress levels
personal stress is partly dependent on
what you choose to do okay so for me i
gave up the ceo role
2017 i think it was two years in yeah
so for me i can argue my stress levels
are lower now so for me
the stress of being a ceo was greater
than i feel my role now even though
we're a much bigger company
i think stress is a strange one i think
stress is obviously essential in life
however it depends on how you define
what your ex actually mean for me the
stress of being ceo was i didn't like
doing that role it was not pleasurable
for me because i was doing stuff i hated
doing so
i've got much bigger responsibilities
now
but i much prefer doing what i do
because i'm cmo i focus on what i think
i'm good at and i enjoy doing that
so if i was ceo now i would have i would
have broken a long time ago right so
it's just not the right job for me you
spread yourself over lots of stuff
so maybe instead of thinking about it's
going to get a lot worse or it's going
to get when it gets bigger maybe if
you're feeling a lot of i'm saying
stress and you're worried about the
future maybe look at what you're doing
and try and get rid of some of it maybe
you're doing stuff that's not right for
you doesn't fit you
outsource it recruit somebody else
to do it um because typically the stuff
that really gets on you like i had to do
um
i'm not very good at writing i had to
write something personal the other day
for a project with work and i can't
really say anything about but i had to
write it and it took me i kept some
people chasing me chasing me chasing
because you know you sort of
put off doing something you don't like
doing or you're not very good at
and the stuff you do like doing you
can't stop thinking about it you can't
stop doing so maybe just review what
you're doing because i don't think it
does i'm not sure for me the bigger the
company the more
stress you've got because you've got
more people to help out you could easily
argue it's easier now i think in the
early days when i was doing you know on
day one of fuel there was only me nobody
else i did every single job yeah
well surely that's harder than doing
having five 10 50 people working for you
interesting how did you decide that you
wanted to not be ceo and become cmo
instead it was pretty easy for me
because um i think there's one one month
in particular where i think i spent the
whole month doing xero marketing zero
brand zero product
and i just
it's felt like super ineffective use of
my time the stuff that i'm good at i'm
not doing the stuff that i'm not good at
i am doing
it didn't make any sense to me yeah so
it was very easy to say look this is i'm
wasting my time doing
um stuff i'm not enjoying so why not
find somebody who's really good at doing
that yeah and then i can focus on what i
am good at how did you find the ceo
uh linkedin in one hour no way yeah it
was it was pretty easy what i did is i
actually um
i've got the recruiter tool and you just
go in there and i think i listed out a
load of sort of
well i wanted somebody with food
experience and i wanted brands which
were not the massive corporates because
i think sometimes massive corporates you
can be
you can
what's the right word sometimes just too
far away from the uh the uh cold face to
actually be doing work so i wanted
somebody who'd been in a ceo role md
role
um operation director role those sorts
of so i just put those job titles in
and i selected about 20 or 30 brands
which i which were in the food business
that i thought were small enough to
actually have the person doing
day-to-day really important work
and uh
it pumped out 20 people or something
like that i scanned through them
james was one of the ones i saw
and um
looked his cv or his linkedin profile
looked good
and then passed it on to a recruiter we
were working with to sort of lined up
the first interviews
and uh that was it
pretty straightforward yeah
okay did you
not want to recruit from within like
promote from within oh we were too there
was nobody nobody at that sort of level
at the time you know we were it was very
early and um
because i was doing that role i think
the most senior person below me at the
time
i'm not sure
i think we had a
finance and operation manager who
effectively was
the only person in that team maybe a
couple of people underneath them that
was it
very very early they were on you know
they were manager level
because i guess for some people uh at
least in tech when when the founder
doesn't become the ceo it's often like a
big like ego type thing they're like huh
this is my company though i want to be a
ceo of it it sounds like that wasn't
really a thing for you you'd kind of
gone beyond that you were like you know
what i want to do the stuff i'm
interested in focus on the marketing
that's my good that's what i'm good at
yeah um let's leave the executiveness to
the other yeah i think uh i don't think
i've got a very big ego and uh i didn't
enjoy doing it and it's um it's a hard
job
and i think i've said to a couple other
founders asked me about this i said look
you're always going to be the founder
ceos change the founder can't change
right you're you know on
you know wikipedia the founder of nike
is going to be the same person forever
right that cannot change you don't worry
about that you're not going to get
forgotten
um
so
you know you know the way i see it she
was
my baby yeah you wanted to afford to fit
he wanted to fulfill its potential and
if that's the best route
then do it i think sometimes people hold
on to this because they don't want to i
don't know what it is they don't want to
get forgotten or whatever it is they
hold on to a role for far too long and i
don't think it wasn't fun for me
so over time you know you started off
with a powder and then it seems you've
expanded out into the kind of the hot
meals the pre-mades the protein bars
i've got a friend who i was having
dinner with yesterday um i think they
worked with heel at some point they've
like got a spreadsheet literally like
rating every single heel product in
terms of like its taste and blind taste
testing and all this other super on the
whole optimization of life yeah kind of
vibe um how did
how did do you sort of evolve the
product line over time from powder into
into these other things one of our
values is sort of product and customer
obsession i think if you focus on what
customers want yeah
pretty good place to be rather than i
think sometimes people look at
competitors and copy competitors i think
you listen to your customers because
your customers will be a different group
of people so if you copy somebody else's
product and give it to your customers
that might not like it if you give
customers what they want you're in a
much better place we we're d2c so we
listen to our customers thousands of
times a day
you can't give them all what they want
you can't please them all with separate
products and you have to avoid um i
think they always talk about tech
businesses you can't give them all the
features they want was it become too
cluttered so sometimes you need to
declutter
so we try and keep our range pretty
small we've only got seven products
um
but we do listen to what they want and
if you hear it enough times i don't
believe in surveys i don't believe going
out asking people i think it needs to be
given to you without them you asking
them so i look at um
uh rejecters of fuel so on facebook you
know on our ads you'll get people saying
i've never bought this product because
i'll look at that
um if that pops up enough times i think
well if i do give you that would you buy
it
and same for customers they'll say i
really love your product but this and
that needs to come through
i'm saying organic sources i think if
you ask people they typically will try
and give you what they think you're
asking for or what might make them sound
good at times they need to be natural
we've got a forum as well where we hear
a lot of feedback from people so reading
between the lines people for a long time
said i want more protein i want less
carbs
and i want a a natural sweetener so we
created black edition which became our
number one product yeah that's the one i
use there you go and the powder form
right there so we gave people what they
want so that's typically how we do it
um save for hot and savory same sort of
principle i've been asking for i wanna i
want it hot yeah i wanna say hot and
savoury i want something that's got more
whole foods in it i want something i can
chew more i want something more like a
traditional meal so we created the hot
and savoury product
nice
so what's what's what's next for heal ah
next i can't really tell you oh um the
product all i can say is that uh mpd
team are really good they run sorry what
mpd so new product development oh okay
cool yeah so they reporting to me and we
work and we've got a really exciting
product pipeline
and uh we're working on anything like up
to 30 projects at a time okay
and what i do is we work on stuff and
sometimes you have to go down the path
be realized before you use a dead end so
we experiment try stuff uh speak to
people
mock stuff up because sometimes it gets
rejected because it ends up being too
expensive or it's just not possible to
make or actually
people don't like it for some reason or
another so there's lots of reasons why
it ends up we killing a project you got
started before you find out the answer
you can't just think of idea reject it
straight i want to try it first so we
work on lots of stuff and um
yeah there's some interesting things
coming okay so i think people quite
often sort of position us as this sort
of powdery weird product yeah but in
theory you can make anything nutrition
complete any food category you could go
into making nutrition complete so we
could go into some quite interesting
categories and have a uspf over other
people because they don't typically
optimize nutrition they're optimizing
for taste and texture which is not
essential in life primary purpose of
food clearly is nutrition that's what
you actually need so we're optimizing
for the right stuff so if we we can go
into any category really interesting um
and even some other stuff that's
interesting as well we could be working
on that
um
if you
had your time again are there any things
any sort of big big mistakes you'd say
you've made or things that you regret
that you would that you would have
wanted to do differently
i'm a strong believer in that no regrets
if you go back in time and change
something would you be where you are
today you could be further back
so
uh probably not because i think where
we've got is really um much further than
i ever expected
and um would i do anything differently
if i really could and end up today in
the same place
um
a couple of times we recruited and made
mistakes
really hard to recruit we were talking
about this briefly earlier it is really
hard to recruit the right person for the
right job
we spend a lot of time i think we've got
better at it now so if i went back i
probably would apply some of our
recruitment principles today to those
early people
so um i'll give you a quick overview
what we do now so we
we've got internal recruiters now i
think the beauty of internal recruiters
are is they know your brand inside out
they really know what you want so they
can pick better people so we have so
that's a benefit cost saving two
probably if you look at it recruiting
can be quite expensive so internal
recruiters i would have probably bought
some of those on board earlier
the recruitment process now is quite
extensive we probably you could have up
to six rounds
so
um not all on separate days not like
it's going to take six days i
insist now on some sort of test
and it should be a
you know not like a
iq exam or something like that it should
be something very specific to your role
so you might give something a case study
do a case study present it back to us
the reason is is because i think that
interview processes or interviews can be
quite artificial environments and i've
experienced people have been very good
at interviewing
um terrible at the job and vice versa
one of my best employees he was a terror
he was terrible at the interviews quite
you know
very nervous
um
didn't but i saw something in him and
gave him a chance this was very early
he's end up being one of our best
employees right so i think that you
can't judge just purely on an interview
process it's very fake environment
you're never going to go for an
interview process at work you're going
to do work so why why not do a test
which is closer to work
we always have a culture fit interview
as well that person can veto so say
you're the hiring manager and you're
looking for a graphic designer you find
this graphic design is really really
good
but he has to fit in with the rest of
the team so we make sure two people have
got nothing to do with your department
interviewing from a culture point of
view if he doesn't fit with the rest of
the team we don't want that person in
the business because that can end up
causing conflicts or problems somewhere
else in the business and that's why
people leave and i don't want anybody
leaving his joint
uh that that team can veto that person
even if they're the best graphic
designer in the world i can still say i
don't want them um i do a culture fit
interview still do it now yeah
i can veto right on the on the culture
for interviewer in interviews
are you like are you trying to ask a
question of is this someone you want to
have a beer with i like are you doing
like a i get a good vibe do you have
like specific questions that they need
answers to what's what's the process
here i i personally do have a range of
questions i ask same uh each time so
questions could be simple as like um
tell me which culture you've worked in
which is fitted you best oh nice right
yeah
there's no clear right answer to that
correct yeah so
just because it might just not fit you
as an individual and obviously i was
asking the same question which culture
have you worked with in that you've not
does not fitted you at all that's used
and clearly if that doesn't sound like
our culture then there wouldn't be the
right person right so it could be
questions along those lines yes i i
typically i think in the back of my head
could i spend a lot of time with this
person because you're going to be at
work for 40 hours a week that's a long
time
and um so if you think that person is
going to be you know difficult to work
with can it be a bit rude or arrogant
there's some people who don't want to
work with right so one of our key values
is don't be a dick right
so you want people you're going to want
to spend time with because you've got to
sit next to them they've got to interact
with other people and they've got to
speak to people outside the business
represent the brand as well so there's
there is lots of sort of nuance to that
but really fundamentally are they a nice
person do you want to spend time with
them okay so you've got the test you've
got the culture for interviews yep um
what else do you have in the recruitment
pipeline that uh so you would probably
see
your immediate manager you might see the
senior person in that particular team as
well you might see some juniors in that
particular team culture fit me culture
fit and then obviously the the um the
recruiter will spend time with you and
they do the first stage really
fundamentally to get past and then one
of those stages you do a test in so you
might see up to six six different stages
to that wow okay that's quite a lot i
think it's it's uh our churn rate has
been incredibly low so over the years
we've lost very few people i said with
240 people
of people i really wanted to keep
three four people
really low we have had people leave yeah
but sometimes that's fine that does
happen people might leave because they
want to move countries they wanna my
first employee that i always sort of
regret she she left but she had done
spanish at cambridge sorry russian at
cambridge and she wanted to speak
russian on a regular basis we don't sell
russia so she couldn't but so nothing to
do about that that's that's so be it but
in terms of people that actually wanted
to go and work for another company very
very rarely has that happened
for
let's say someone's listening to this
and they're sort of you know just coming
out of university they're they're
applying for jobs and want to want a job
at one of the green brands
as someone who's been on the other side
of kind of recruiting a bunch of people
what are
what are some things that potential
candidates do that helps help them stand
out in a good way this is this is so
easy i can't believe this still happens
right i reckon less than
i reckon less than five percent of
people actually write a covering letter
right so because it's so easy now to
sort of spam people with cvs you go to
indeed or wherever it is and you just
drop your cv and just send it
in the early days i was being really
ruthless because i was doing all the
recruitment the first 10 or 15 people i
did all the recruitment myself because i
was trying to run a business be the ceo
do all the work do
i didn't have time to do this so my
easiest filtering technique was if you
didn't write me a covering letter to say
why you wanted to work for you i feel
like you don't care if you don't care i
don't care about you
so if you did that and you delete all
the ones that have got no attachments
apart from the cv
you'll have five percent left so it's a
very quick filter mechanism out of those
five
there will be probably half of them
maybe more will be
standard covering letters i want to work
for your company insert company name yep
blah blah blah blah blah it's very rare
that anybody goes beyond that
what the best i think if you want to
stand out there's two things i would say
is write a company you know just choose
the companies you want to work for and
then and then find out why you want to
work for them and say that
mention some things about yourself or
why you can add value to that company so
i could add value to sure because of
these things and make it specific to
huel right so i don't know say he's
looking at graphic design say i've
looked at these two pages or i've looked
at something on your website and i saw
there was a mistake here i could have
made it better there that shows you put
some real time and effort into it
and then the final thing is if you want
to go really far and go um and really
stand out i think in the whole time i've
had a few people do stuff like this
where they would actually
uh create something physical and send it
in so i think i said to you earlier
there was one of our employees
she and i think her dad actually helped
her she wanted to stand out there was no
job for her at the time so she just she
she'd seen she'll use george she wanted
to work for the brand so she loved the
packaging so much that on our sort of
label on the back she took the same
template and um
uh turned her cv into one of our labels
so instead of saying uh best before date
it will say born on day that was a date
of birth and instead of like ingredients
it would be her attributes and skills or
whatever and nutritional profile would
be her employment history she changed
around did that so that really makes you
stand out and then send it to the hiring
team leader sort of thing so i think she
wanted a marketing job so she ended
directly to me at the time so so that
and when you when you get one of those
it really does stand out
yeah we did a big bunch of recruitment
uh a few months ago
recruiting for like eight positions at
the same time
and one of the positions we were
recruiting for was a videographer and we
had like 100 200 people apply or
something like that and there was one
guy who actually made a video and was
the only person who made a video to be
like whatever and
sort of we ended up not going with him
in the end because he just didn't have
the right level of experience that we
needed but that was an instant hack to
just get to the top right we need to
bring this guy in for an interview yeah
whereas everyone else was like okay
let's send them the asynchronous
interview let's look through their cv
let's make sure this guy was immediately
by just standing out with a bit of
effort you know a day's worth of putting
putting something together
um just immediately got to the top of
the pile correct i mean clearly if you
want to be ceo of nike or something like
that just send in doing this one label
or something like that that's not going
to get the job you need to obviously
have it have it backed up and being the
right person for that job but if you're
the right person for that job you
strongly believe it is
an hour of your time half an hour of
your time not going to take very long to
do but you could land your dream job
just by doing that little bit of extra
work your cv already exists there's no
work so a covering letter which you can
attach when you're doing to an indeed or
most things you should be covering
letter thing yeah you can attach that
half an hour an hour of your time really
spend a bit of you know not a lot of
time but spend something on and you will
stand out i cannot believe our record is
less than five percent
can i ask a little bit about firing
people yep that's like often people who
start companies say that's the hardest
part of the job
um i've had to do it once um and it
wasn't a nice experience
do you have like a
a philosophy or a model when it comes to
kind of if like recognizing someone's
not right for the role and then what you
do about it yep
it's yeah it's horrible i think if they
are not performing
then obviously in some cases you can
move them right there could be a better
job for them within the same
organization it depends
if they're not performing because they
just are
lazy or whatever then that's much easier
to do
so we've had people where i don't know
in customer service it's very easy to
see performance because there's tickets
so there's a number of tickets per day
one person's tickets were
15
10 times smaller nearly everybody else's
they just weren't working as hard as
anybody else that's quite easy because
you just pulled them up for you explain
to them you everybody's doing this
number you're doing this number you
you're not working on somebody you can't
be
um so those ones are fairly easy the
ones which are tougher is the ones where
it's a little bit more difficult to put
your finger on exactly why they're not
fitting in or they're not performing
um and we've had a couple which have
been quite
uh emotional when people have been told
clearly you
you want to give people a chance to
improve so the first stage is to go
through a process of explaining to them
where they've gone wrong and what you
think or what is expected of them
um
a recent example of somebody where we
did this
and we gave them multiple opportunities
to to up their game
and they didn't they just didn't respond
they just didn't show willing and it was
quite interesting because the person had
come on board um and had
sort of bait and switched us really they
had put a lot of effort in to get the
job
got it and then once they got it got
their feet under the table they just
sort of chilled out and then they got
told it wasn't good enough
didn't respond got told they weren't
good enough didn't respond but totally
weren't good enough so eventually then
it was it was fairly easy because we
give them multiple opportunities so all
i'm saying is i think you need to speak
to the individuals explain to what's
wrong how they can improve what is
expected and then give them an
opportunity to to improve
i've never really experienced anybody
where there isn't there is a valid
reason why that's happened if they're
obviously experiencing problems you need
to sometimes ask the question is there's
something else we don't know about
you're not telling us i haven't really
had an example of where that actually
happened
but um
you know it's important to find that out
you know
usually if there's something really bad
going on at home or or their personal
life that comes to service quicker and
actually the ones that where that's
happened is usually us saying to them we
can see you're not happy but their work
was still good they were still crafting
have you found that in instances where
you do give feedback and say hey this
thing needs improving has it
improved more often than it's not
improved or not
no typically it doesn't change it
doesn't improve a great deal i think
it's because they're just
either out of their depth yeah or they
just don't have the
the desire or the um to change that's
just the way they are and sometimes um
it usually happens quite quickly within
somebody joining a company i i've seen
it's very rare you have somebody you
know working for two years really good
and then their performance drops it
usually join and it's it's never been
great it's always been a bit bad
typically my experience has been
typically
they're not i mean they could be really
nice people and you give them i think in
the early days we were probably worse at
this and so sometimes you'd have people
for six months or a year
and you just think oh if we do this we
could get them to do that give them a
bit of extra training give them a bit it
typically never changes so
i think once you see it work on it but
in the early days probably should have
pulled the plug on people a bit quicker
on some of them because if it's not
right for us it's probably not right for
them either it probably would be better
of somewhere else yeah so i guess
philosophically speaking you're um you
want to give them a chance but you're
thinking in the back of your mind that
like last
ninety percent of times i did this it
didn't work out but hey we'll give you a
chance anyway that's got that giving
people a chance i can't even think of an
example actually i can there's there is
a person i'm thinking of now where
they
um
they have improved yeah there has been
one more example of somebody that has it
has improved they definitely up their
game they're still
um got some fundamental traits which
probably aren't quite rolled for that
right for that particular role yeah so i
think we probably will have have to
replace them eventually but they've
definitely up their game and that will
probably um extend that that period
where they'll be able to work for the
company for another year or two i think
but eventually they're going to hit the
ceiling yeah how do you how do you think
about things like culture like culture
is one of these big words that everyone
everyone talks about yeah what's the
sort of culture that you're trying to
make it heal and i guess how do you
how do you mold it in that direction so
i think culture is yeah i think it's
uh super super important and super
important to give it due care and
attention it will happen naturally
but i think uh the hardest culture will
probably be a company that's been
existing for a very long time i've
worked two places and once you've got a
culture it's very hard to change that
culture
luckily with your because i started with
a blank sheet of paper
and i was a founder and i was there i
think it's been fairly
easy to do in some ways because
i didn't start this company just to make
money i wanted something to be proud of
i wanted a company where i was going to
work there as well so it's very easy to
sort of say i want to work somewhere
where i'm yeah there's no dicks i want a
workplace where people are nice
and i want but i want to perform i want
to get good results to create a culture
where
um we we are you know market leader we
achieve great things but we don't burn
people out and people don't want to
leave every two years because it's such
a soul-destroyed place to work you know
they they don't there's no fights
there's no crying in the office don't
want any of that so we want to really
look after people but we don't want to
have we want to have that energy and
that
that sort of passion to achieve great
things and so have higher targets so i
tried to merge those two together so
sort of stuff that we do is we do
recruit well i think that we do
have ambitious targets but not not so
ambitious you're never going to achieve
any of them
um
we do look after people we have a people
team
uh that people team look after the team
and make sure there's anybody with any
problems we do provide a lot of perks
she always got share options quite
generous share options as well
and so again we're all
hopefully
more on the level playing field together
and rowing in the same direction and
then we do lots of additional perks like
we've got gym at work we bring in the pt
we have um you know free shield around
the office i went to a posh office the
other day a very
rich company they're charging one pound
eighty for a coffee don't have to do
you know even stuff like that i think
makes a difference we've you know we
really try and think about doing the
right thing at all times nice
that's really cool yeah i think that's
one thing we're starting to think about
a lot harder now that the team has sort
of sort of accidentally become 17 people
who are like all right now we need to
really think hard about this culture
thing and have you written anything down
we've got core values and stuff but
they're all very rough first drafty but
no we haven't really really written down
any cultural principles yeah i'd start
it yeah just think about what it is and
words that you may use and phrases you
may use just write it down i mean i
couldn't probably could send you my
first deck that i did it's pretty crude
and pretty rough we've refined it
immediately better but there's there's
some very famous culture decks out there
i think that um netflix one is one
that's often used very long now it's
probably a bit too long maybe a bit too
specific if you looked at the the
netflix one did a crude version of that
a quick crude version um talk about you
know principles some stuff
stuff you don't want to do the stuff you
do want to do um
but yeah so we have two sets we have uh
in terms of values we have uh shaw's dna
sets as a company so nutrition first
takes a close second
and then we have how to be a heuligon
which is what we sort of call all of our
customers and all of our employees will
be huge ligands and there'll be stuff in
there like um you know number one
is uh make customers happy number two is
don't be a dick stuff like that
sick
um any time sorry just one of the things
that is um
i still induct everybody comes into the
business and i think that it's very easy
for a culture deck to become dusty put
in a draw nobody sees it so what we've
done is that when everybody joins i do
it so i'll deduct everybody who joins
and um give them my thoughts on culture
from my perspective
so don't be a dick's like you know don't
don't gossip around the office no that's
not allowed i don't accept that if i
hear that you'd be in big trouble
we print out those two sets of values on
just a little sticker everybody's laptop
in the business should have it on stick
it on there when they first join so at
least it sort of tries to keep it top of
mind
and then um
you know then you've got to live it you
have to live those so you don't want to
work
right sort of flaky stuff that's
a bit aloof never going to happen
so just try and remember and try and
quote those things back to somebody if
they're doing something wrong and try
and you know make sure you try and yeah
bring them to life and so
it's very easy i think it's healed to a
certain extent we don't have a floor
which is just from management you know
like james and this our ceo myself we
all sit you know open plan offices all
sit together and try and sort of lift
those values together awesome yeah i
think when i first started out of the
business though i i i came across things
like culture and like values and
missions i was like oh what is this
[ __ ] but now i'm like oh crap i
really wish i had paid more attention to
this sort of yeah somebody live in one
thing that
i think is harder now is the working
from home i think that has made culture
harder so i think when you're in the
office together
and you have beers on a friday afternoon
it's very easy or much easier to build
that together it's a little bit like a
football team or something much easier i
imagine a football team you've never got
together the team can't be together yeah
so i think you you've a lot got a lot of
remote workers i'm assuming we do yeah i
i i do find that
it's so much nicer when people are in
the office but also it's like i can't
assist on people in the office because
covered and stuff so it's like like how
do we
keep the
you know people who are not coming to
the office fairly regularly as involved
as the people who are in here and just
hanging out just daily and lunch and
coffees and things like that do you do
um that we have uh our christmas parties
quite big oh yeah it's put quite a lot
of time left into the christmas party
again it has to be everybody together no
teams are allowed to go and have their
own christmas parties it's one team or
no teams
and then we have a birthday party on our
anniversary of our birth um each year as
well but that's another big party so we
had a big one we've spent a lot of time
and effort it takes months of organizing
have those two big ones we have two big
ones people will
the american team don't fly over but the
london team the train team and the
birmingham team all have those parties
together so those could be events where
you get sort of home workers together
yeah that's a good shout out yeah we had
we had sort of a mini christmas party
but then again covet put a pro because
we had this whole plan we were like all
right let's let's repair it down but i
do want to do things like twice a year
kind of either a ski trip or like an
adventure holiday where everyone goes
off to somewhere and we fly in the
remote workers as well and yeah do that
as like a thing we did do we did uh yeah
during cove we did do one that was quite
good i think they set out these kits
these cocktail kits were all on a remote
party where we had to sit and make
cocktails at home by yourself
and then we broke up into little groups
like little groups of ten or something
where you had like you'd have chat
together and sort of drinking together
that was
his best
yeah um any tips for
juggling uh family life relationships
that kind of stuff while building a
business and being quite like
entrepreneur vibes i don't think there's
many things you can do in terms of
juggling in
at certain times so i think hopefully
you'd want your your partner or your
husband your wife whatever to to really
understand there's gonna be a time when
you have to knuckle down
and uh you might get a bit manic you
might get so you know long long hours
you might look a little bit unhealthy
you might have been doing crazy hours
and you might get you know a bit of
pressure to sort of relax but sometimes
if you know this is the right thing to
do
as long as you know there's an that they
know and you know this is not going to
go in 30 it might go for years but it
might not go for 10 years it might go on
for a year or two
then i think if you're both aware
there's an end goal there
then i think
i think that's the best thing you do i
think it's the best thing you can do
clearly you can't do that seven days a
week for years on end so there will be
times when you can go out but obviously
sometimes the the day when you're not
working is a day you don't really want
to go out because they want to chill out
and relax
so that doesn't work either i think it
can be um it i'm trying to say i think
it will cause conflict sometimes
i'm not sure i've got much much advice
on that i think that sometimes you have
to just do it yeah yeah do you do you do
things like you know having having a
hard stop in the evenings and then
you're not gonna check email or is it
all kind of integrated
i'm not a massive um
regimented planner i think that it's uh
when there's something to be done i
typically try and do it
um and i don't like saying right sundays
are clear because you've got a massive
panic or massive problem on a sunday i
wouldn't like to say like sunday's
always clear or i'm always finishing
after seven o'clock at night
i'm not very good at doing that no
holiday sorry when we're on holiday
relax his brain just goes mental yeah
well it's a little bit like shower in
the morning you know you're supposed to
think very clearly in the shower i think
sometimes when you do go on holiday and
you're supposed to or you're having a
meal out with somebody that's when
you're not at work and sometimes your
brain is still thinking about work and
so stuff comes into your head and you
think oh god tell us about that now yeah
i i think if you're dating i think maybe
the other way around rather than the
entrepreneur changing i think it could
be the other person
could you could you tell them to
be more understanding sometimes i think
it is tough but i think if you're if
you're um yeah dating somebody who's
just uh you know got a nine to five job
then
that's a different experience and dating
somebody who's does this yeah yeah i
think that's that's something i find if
i'm if i'm on holiday or if i'm you know
on a weekend i'm not working that that's
when i have the best ideas and suddenly
i'll open up slack and be like
and everyone's like whoa what the hell
is going on and i'm like oh crap
i need to refrain from just spamming the
slack uh channels with various like
ideas and like oh we could do this we
could do that and just i'll say i'll
i'll either schedule it for a monday
morning or i'll save it but you are i
think you're in a manic world i think it
is
i think sometimes that was the most
exciting times is the early days for me
when you are making everything up from
scratch and sometimes those those yeah
odd ideas that are springing into your
mind at the odd times sometimes can be
really important
nice um this has been great can we add
some social media questions yeah sure
sick oh fantastic okay so we posted on
twitter instagram and linkedin so we
have a bunch of questions um excellent
so we'll just pick pick some good ones
uh we've got cameron who asks what's
been your biggest mistake and what have
you learned from it
i get asked this one a lot yeah it's a
very hard one to answer because i think
you sort of asked us a little bit
earlier
biggest mistake
probably the biggest mistake you was
ever made i probably can't tell you
about
and
i think there's nothing to learn from
that really it's just mistakes happen
right some things happen and sometimes
you're unavoided you're gonna make
sort of talk to somebody over your
career you're gonna make tens of
thousands of decisions you can't be
right all the time even i think i am
generally right
i i'm not sure what the really the
biggest mistake really would be in terms
of value back to the the this person i'm
not sure
um trevor says how do you power through
the part of starting a business when
you're not making money
okay that is a good one i think we sort
of talked about a little bit i think you
have to have this vision this goal of
where you want to be
and um
you know
if you if you if you want to be up here
then i think sometimes it's the exciting
times when you know you haven't got
there you know like i think quite often
steve's talked about this where some
people have already got to the top
sometimes that's the worst time so
sometimes it's exciting when you know
you're going up up a hill
when you're not making money
uh it
okay so in the affiliate world it was
quite easy because quite quickly you can
make some money yeah whereas for you it
was two years
before i made a penny right that must
that was hard like i said i never nearly
gave up so if it's something you can if
you buy if you can generate some money
so say you're starting a restaurant so
you have to build a restaurant and you
have to start that from scratch you
could take a lot of time but could you
do i don't know a
dinner party event or something to at
least get some money in the door doing
something around a similar type of
subject can you do a mini version a
pop-up or something like that
if it's something that's like building
some tech that's going to take years
that would be really hard to to push
through but i think you have to just
remind yourself there's some motivating
goal not that i just want a bit of money
that my life's going to be better my
family's life is going to be better so
you'll be more motivating that should
keep you going sick
um
zack says what's the hardest part of
being a business owner
um
i like it i'm not sure is for me it
doesn't feel
hard as such
um
i think trying to please trying to keep
um you've got a lot of sort of i'm not
saying stakeholders is right phrase but
you've got you know you've got your team
you've got your customers you're trying
to keep a lot of people happy and you
can never keep everybody happy
impossible so there's gonna be some
times but
i've got a bit of the
thick skin now and i'm a sort of in
marathon mode now that i feel that in
the early days you're sprinting later on
you're in a marathon mode and therefore
you know you can't do so much so before
i used to be really sort of quite sort
of um hectic overnight i wouldn't go to
bed until stuff was done
now i'm a bit more chilled and i can let
those sort of
things
i can deal with them a lot more easily
now i think you have to just relax a
little bit sometimes yeah nice
um ash says what's your advice for
teenage entrepreneurs teenage
entrepreneurs well
you're a teenage entrepreneur correct
yeah yeah i guess so i didn't make any
money while i was a teenager
i think the the key thing for for
you know um
is to probably learn i think podcasts
are excellent way to do that i i've seen
you've got loads of books here yeah i'm
a terrible reader i don't like reading
at all um but reading books would be
good as well but for podcasts for me
hearing someone's voice i've listened to
that's much more like storytelling i
could hear it i can hear the inflection
in someone's voice i get it so i'd say i
would say listen and learn
but also do you can read and learn first
your life and never do a single things
you have to start at some point so start
something which is not going to cost you
a lot of money start something and just
get some experience under your belt and
then obviously you should be able to
apply some of things you've heard in the
podcast and if you're not making
progress then something's wrong so
course correct and do something
different but i would say start
something the chances are the first
business you you start or the first
website you start is going to go nowhere
right the fifth one might go nowhere so
start get something and maybe drop it
quite quick and move on to something
else but then the temp when you start
might be better so i was sort of
you know the the the business i start
that year i probably did five or ten
websites in that first year and um and
then i sort of started getting some
traction with one of them and that's the
one that went on but don't worry about
it don't commit don't like spend six
years planning something and then
realize it's going nowhere i would sort
of start something but there's so many
little sort of things you could do you
could sell on etsy now you could sell
uh you could start a website you could
do a course on skillshare you can do you
can do lots of things quite quick and
easily now and if they start getting a
bit of traction and double down on they
don't get any traction and move on to
something else
yeah
i think i think that's something that we
did really well in the early days of
this business when it was just me or
just like a few of us but as the team's
grown in size i found that we're just
taking a lot longer to do things and i
guess this is this just happens
naturally but i'm i'm trying to think oh
could we maybe be a little bit more
scrappy like we used to be back in the
day yep while at the same time yeah is
it is is that
how how do you think about that
trade-off between like kind of like team
team getting bigger and just stuff
getting slower yeah
well that's that is absolute classic
isn't it that's just like um
you know we use the example of um halo
top which is an ice cream you know halo
top sailor top is an ice cream i think
it came from north america you can buy
this country now so they start with two
people i think less than seven years ago
maybe about seven years ago
and then they sell hundreds of millions
of pounds worth of ice cream per year
and they were two people and uh
they got to market with a low calorie
ice cream so what they did is notice
people like ice cream took out the sugar
put some stevia in and put a little bit
of whey protein in pretty simple they
made a product which is tastes less less
good arguably than um
ben and jerry's or something like that
but because lower calories it sells
loads
and they start with two people um
unilever that owns ben and jerry's they
took years to get that to market sort of
similar type of product so you could
move a lot faster this little classic
sort of innovator's dilemma the bigger
you are the slower you're going to move
right i think coke life which was a one
with stephen took five years to get to
market or something crazy you could make
it in the kitchen in five minutes so i
think the beauty of being young is that
you've got less commitments you can do
anything you like so just do something
do it scrappy do you know scrappy's good
i think scrappy's excellent get stuff
done because if you take a long time to
plan until it's perfect it's probably
too late you know you want to launch
something
read a book on minimal viable product
that is a good good concept
um but as you get bigger you don't want
to do minimal viable product anymore
because you're saying this is too short
this is too crap i can't launch this so
yeah we do experience that for sure
and you have to fight against that and
there's a sort of balancing act so yeah
our products we launch now we can't be
as scrappy as we first were so the
beauty of being young is that you or
you're early and you haven't got a
business you haven't got a brand is that
you could do a really scrappy crappy
version but give it to your friends sell
it to your friends and get some get some
feedback and learn
improve learn improve learn improve nice
yeah one thing we've been thinking since
the discussion with um steve from
gymshark is that can we reorganize our
sort of team of
15 20 people into sort of these three
people squads for each different project
because i find that three three three or
four is like a good number because it
starts to get to like six seven eight
for a single project it starts to feel
like everything is slow for no reason
okay um so now we're as of monday we're
gonna we're gonna experiment with what
it's like to do three months quads for a
bunch of our different things see what
that's like and how are those squads
organized you have they they've got
project lead or how is it done yeah so
what we're thinking is when it comes to
youtube videos um it would be that it
would be like the host a writer and a
producer okay and that would be it um at
the moment what we have is like a team
of four writers and a team of like four
hosts and everyone's sort of trying to
do a bit of everything and yeah it's a
whereas this would be host writer
producer working in like three week
sprints to just come up with an idea
write it film it the following week edit
it the following week release repeat
that process you scope it out before you
do it do you actually sort of research
the market come up with a concept think
it through or you just do work um we do
a bit of that um so we spent about a
week doing the whole figuring out what's
going on competitor analysis market
research that kind of stuff yeah i spent
i try to do a lot of that yeah because i
think you can think a lot faster than
you can do yeah so think spend a lot of
time thinking and i think one thing
people make a mistake of is that they
might think i want this is the the
solution this is the right solution i'm
going to take six months to get to that
solution well but that's maybe only
thinking one one level ahead you know
talk about you know a good chess player
would think i know six seven eight nine
moves ahead so you've got to think about
the not the next move you've got to
think about the next six seven moves and
i think it's far easier like a chess
player probably would they would go
through those and what's the what's the
competitor or the what's going to happen
what's going to come back what's going
to problems how that's going to work
so if you think for all the permutations
of all the things you could do all the
directions you'd do you can think that
through a lot thinking faster than doing
it and you might realize that is good
now but actually has blocked boxed me in
for the future so come back go down a
different path and then that's still not
right and go down a different path and
then you hopefully will get to the get
to the right path and you commit to that
path nice
yeah like a really solid like whiteboard
stage just like getting ideas on the
page and i don't even i don't even use
whiteboards i just i do sort of research
the markets a lot and sometimes you
might say you've got an idea
chances are you can find someone who's
done something similar
and if you see that idea never took off
then obviously you killed that one but
it's sort of a bit of a signal better
tell that that probably there's
something fundamentally not not
appealing in that ideal that that
execution so it might be you can iterate
on it make it better but it might be the
garden i've seen that i've seen that
done a few times that's not going to
work right so that might help you
rule out the options you've got because
when you've got a whiteboard you've got
unlimited options there's so many things
you could do which one are you going to
do which one you're going to commit to
yeah okay so we've got uh leper who says
with so much information overload and so
many quick ways to make money on the
internet how do you find the one thing
to get into or yeah how do you how do
you get started with i guess picking
picking your option when there's all
these options related to what we just
talked about somebody's trying to sell
your course
on how to make money that is really
tricky because
that might not be the right one
it is really tricky to know i think
uh i would always think niche is better
than
um the big win especially if you're very
early try and pick something very very
small and that can be incredibly
valuable because the competition will be
less and it's much easier to do
something very bespoke and you know
where you're going to reach that person
try to solve one of the world's great
problems is going to be bloody hard to
do right so start simple do a very
simple thing and just do it and do it
scrappy get it going get a little bit of
money because when you've got money you
can invest money in other things
so trying to pick the idea
you get you are gonna guess you're going
to guess but you i i think it's always
easy to be uh you know what's the word
um scratch your own itch so hugh was
scratching my own itch my first business
uh
pretty much chose that particular idea
because there were some big mouths
saying how much money they were earning
in that category
so voucher codes i remember there was an
affiliate forum
forum's a good place for doing research
and there were some people on there sort
of saying how not saying how easy it was
just saying there's so much money here
that's crazy
i thought that was definitely made me
dig into it deeper i did my due
diligence my research looked into it and
then found the opportunity to do a niche
which is just a keyword variant of what
they were doing that nobody was
competing with so it gave me an easy
little niche to go after i didn't even
want massive money these guys would talk
about big big money i didn't even need
that i want that i just wanted enough to
be able to make myself self-sufficient
so i think niche down on something that
maybe already exists
um
and if it's quick and easy test it i
think going back to tim ferriss i think
he's quite keen on testing those sorts
of ideas you know there's a little
example he said
if you want to test something you put uh
what do you say you do an ad yeah like a
few a few dollars of adwords behind it
yeah
quite quick or even you know there's
different ways you can run tests but
that was one of the easier ones you set
up a website you don't have to put check
credit cards you can send people to it
you can see what the traffic you can
work out with conversion rate data you
can do some number crunching on it as
well
um and final question from the q a um
maura says what resources would you
recommend to students who want to start
a business business podcasts books etc
what resources yeah 22 immutable laws of
marketing is obviously number one
um in terms of podcasts you mean natural
life things are going to learn from yeah
back in the day i used to listen to um
this week in startups it's become more
of a news program now so you don't learn
so much i don't think it's newsy but i
think the early podcast they were really
good at talking about how you pitch your
business how you uh position the
business there's lots of that um so that
was really useful i think there's a
whole series of podcasts we should pull
yeah podcast which has been done by y
combinator oh yeah startup school
they've got a whole thing as well yeah
yeah i know you're talking about i'm not
sure i'm not sure exactly what it is but
there's about 20 videos they did and
they're really good lectures they're the
lecturers the really early ones i think
there's a guy called sam which is one of
the founders did it might be startup
school i'm not quite sure but you could
probably put in the show notes we'll
find it
that is really good stuff some of the
first two or three podcasts they did on
there really really good and you know
there's been some pretty serious
businesses come out quite commonly so
they must know what they're talking
about so they were really really
influential i think if you google my
name julian hearn bio i think there's a
list at the bottom there there's some
podcast links there
and um
there's some really good there are some
really good places where you've i've
learned there's no way i would be where
i am today without listening podcasts
yeah same to be honest
um okay final few rapid fire questions
that we ask we ask everyone um
who's had the biggest influence on your
career what would you say i would
probably argue that one book that 22
mutable laws the guys called a guy
called jack reese um i would say without
that i wouldn't be here today now okay
i'm gonna get that book today thank you
uh what's one tip for someone looking
for success
i think the biggest thing for tip for
success is you've got to find some this
motivating thing if you can try and find
something that's going to motivate you
through this thick and thin and it can't
be just money i don't think if you can
find something
then that is the thing that will make
drive you further and faster
nice
um what does the first and last hour of
your day look like um i'm pretty simple
first i was just getting just get up
i don't really have any routines i'm
literally get up fast as i can shower
get to work that's what i typically do
um
anything interested in them not really
come home to a nice cook
in the last hour last hour i do try and
um
my sleep has never been particularly
fantastic i don't think anybody's is
really i do have one of these um oh yeah
aura rings i try to monitor it try and
improve it so i know that it's not
particularly good if i get 80 that's
really good i could have done 60 or 70s
so i do try and be a little bit semi
strict for myself towards the end of the
night don't eat anything late at night
don't do don't go on your phone too much
later at night so the last hour
is pretty much probably chill time
watching tv
not too much um
and try and get some decent sleep nice
um
what material item under around about
100 pounds has added large amounts of
value to your life under 100 i think
this is 250 i think yeah the ring do you
find it's useful because i've got one
but i don't really act on the data it's
like there's two there's two things i
monitor on this there's only two that
i'm interested in one i try to hit this
does a calorie count in terms of the
exercise you've done it's not great for
like weight lift or anything like that
it's purely just to encourage me to do
steps i suppose so they they do a
calorie count thing on there i try to
aim for a thousand burn per day
just an arbitrary number good and then
sleep score i try to aim for sort of 70
plus
so it just keeps me a little bit aligned
because you know i don't know without
this whether i'm getting really bad
sleep or really good so at least it
keeps me i know that if i go out and i
eat late at night it will be low if i
drink it's gonna be even lower so i
think this has been useful it's over a
hundred but i think it has been helpful
i guess the next question is uh what
book would you recommend to anyone
that's probably pretty easy i think my
whole life i've read about five books um
but we have we have mentioned briefly
that four hour work with work week that
was probably um super influential in the
early career nice
um so let's say hu hill gets acquired or
dies for whatever reason and you've now
you're now back to square one you've got
you know you're financially set but um
and you've got all the skills but you
want to start a new thing how would you
go about building that up okay so i'm a
slightly different um
i'd have slightly different objectives
than probably most of your um listeners
so in terms of me i have sort of put a
little bit of time into this because
obviously i know that i'm 50 now so i'm
assuming i've got a certain number of
years left getting towards it so what
would i do
at the moment i'm still a thousand
percent committed to heal this is this
is this is the sort of
once-in-a-lifetime company for me
so i haven't really thought what i would
do post but you do think if you died
which it won't i've got no idea what i
would do if you was very successful and
it gives me you know a huge
life-changing amount that's the one
that's obviously more interesting what
would you do would you do something
which i think would be
um
majorly interesting but very um
world change if you do something really
really serious
money would certainly not be the driving
factor it wasn't the driving factor for
you so it won't be in the future you'd
want to do something that's going to be
ticks a massive box for you so obviously
you know
elon did electric cars that he did like
going to mars i don't space doesn't
really particularly interest me but i'd
probably
focus on something that would
make a huge difference which would be
really
i've got a few little things i'm sort of
interested in but at the moment it's
1000 sure my way my brain works is if i
um like people ask me to do like um
uh you know board roles or something
like that i know that if i start
thinking about something it's very hard
when you're in a shower i don't want to
be thinking about any other company
apart from fuel so at the moment it's
just that nice
um what quote or mantra do you live by i
don't really have one
my friend said on years and years ago
which is a bit odd but it sort of does
sort of work for me and um
especially i think it's sort of along
the lines of just gritty teeth and gets
stuck in right but he sort of said
something like um
um
if it doesn't fit force it right and the
concept between behind that is that some
things just naturally work but sometimes
it doesn't and you have to get
you have to make it work sometimes
making it work means like forcing it to
work and
but it should fit naturally so you
should hopefully find something just
works
and that is the optimum but there's
occasionally when sometimes it won't
work but you need it to work it has to
work and that is the time you go above
and beyond so and sometimes it doesn't
need that much more effort so going back
to body hack earlier i'd gone to the gym
for 10 years
and hadn't seen great improvements but
just by changing one thing which was
basically weighing all of my food so my
calories were bang on
in three months i've made more progress
than in 10 years so i forced it to work
i forced it to happen i changed it and
did something different so i think that
sort of logic and the same for starting
any business you're gonna if you just do
your normal nine to five
i don't think you're gonna make a
success of it i was on a panel once and
somebody said what do you think of four
hour uh four day weeks i sort of smirked
and laughed and i said look
yeah once you're a big corporate
business you can do that but if you're
in a start-up mode or you're trying to
start business i don't think you're ever
going to get it done in full
four days right because somebody else is
going to work seven days they're going
to beat you so you are in a a very very
intense
zone where this thing you're creating
can die at any seconds you have to go
above and beyond you have to force it
through and there will be a time when it
could last a year or two when you're
gritting your teeth and going
above and beyond
final question uh journey or destination
um well
it's got to be a journey right so
yeah the destination's death really
that's the end so
that's where we're all going eventually
so i think journey definitely is the um
uh you know i look back i remember the
early days of you when you're in it it's
flipping hard but you look back and you
go that's definitely the
the fun is the most exciting time so
definitely journey love it julian thank
you so much thank you it's very much a
pleasure it's been i i feel like i've
gotten such a master class in
entrepreneurship from someone who's
been through the trenches at like all
levels of success and yeah just want to
say thank you so much for being so
gracious with your time thank you very
much and uh for making amazing products
which i use on the daily okay i'll bring
the fridge in and we'll get a load of
products sent to you yeah thank you so
much thank you
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are gonna be linked down in the
video description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye